Joe Biden has announced we will respond
to a drone strike that killed three US
soldiers and injured 34 more they say it
was done by iran-backed militia groups
and came from Syria we're now getting a
breaking report from Sky News that as
early as tonight Joe Biden May authorize
military action in the Middle East which
could spark World War II I'm not the
only one who's saying it World War I has
been trending for some time especially
after these three US soldiers had been
killed and there are numerous reports
coming out about the fears escalating
and of course kind of feels like beating
a dead horse but you have many world
leaders saying over and over again over
the past year that we are knocking on
the doors of World War II in fact many
said we are already in it we just don't
know it yet so we'll see I suppose with
all the news now coming out about the
fears of World War III there's a lot to
actually break down but we got big news
on the border everybody's waiting for an
update and what happened with Biden the
Biden Administration and Texas the
National Guard the board of Patrol has
sided with Texas they said they're not
going to interfere interfere they're not
going to be arresting anybody and they
actually disagree with the Supreme
Court's ruling this is from the border
patrol Union so this should be
particularly interesting we'll get into
all that then we got some more uh fun
news Mark Cuban has been arguing over
diversity inclusivity and Equity
programs and he stated publicly on X
that gender and race do
contribute to he says I've never had
anybody solely based on that but it does
play a factor well one of the
commissioners of the EEOC responded to
him saying no you cannot use it in any
way you are dead wrong Mark Cuban seems
to have publicly admitted to violating
the law opening up all of his companies
to massive legal exposure by admitting
they use race and gender in hiring which
is illegal now there people reporting
anybody who's ever or I should say the
the the the what's going around now
anybody who's been fired or refused a
job from any one of his companies now
has grounds for a lawsuit to say it was
because of their Race So this should get
very interesting my my friends but
before we get started I want you all to
head over to facts withth ben.com that's
fcts with ben.com to buy the song Facts
by Tom McDonald and Ben Shapiro you
click purchase options then you select
129 you buy the song you buy that MP3
you download it the link is also
available in the description below this
is not a promotional sponsor spot I am
just friends with Tom and Ben and I
think you guys if we I bought the song
already we all buy the song we put Ben
Shapiro on the Billboard Hot 100 we've
already made Ben Shapiro the number one
rapper in the country Nicki Minaj has
even commented on it congratulating Ben
Shapiro but I'll tell you it's about us
pushing back and taking this territory
in the culture War storming into the
cultural institutions and making our
voices heard Tom McDonald has been
working really really hard for a very
very long time he makes a bunch of
really awesome music he's made he he's
had a bunch of hits but at every turn of
course there are obstacles thrown in his
way and I say this only because it's
happened to us as well we put out a song
whoops billboard all of a sudden doesn't
track the sales we got anymore for some
technical reason okay well if you want
to support Tom McDonald and Ben Shapiro
if you want to Stick it to the machine
and you want to uh Force the corporate
press to acknowledge Ben Shapiro who
doesn't even think rap is music force
them to say okay Ben chapiro is one of
the world's top rappers and bu the song
support our friends uh Tom and Ben and
uh I do appreciate it again not
sponsored but uh by them in any way I
just really hope that they they chart
based on the metrics I have so far it
does look like so long as we keep up
this campaign until Thursday Ben and Tom
should be on the Hot 100 The Bu The the
top 100 songs in the country and
potentially even the top 200 which is
global so I think that would be
fantastic but don't forget also head
over to
timcast.net Our Guest don't forget to
also smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with all of
your friends that is the most powerful
way to really help out joining us talk
about this and everything else is Steve
Baker hey it's good to be here who are
you what do you do who am I what do I do
God that's a hard question actually I've
been around long enough to have done a
lot of things started my life as a
musician oh great yeah yeah did that uh
from the time I was a child and then
became a professional touring musician
when I was a 19yearold punk in college
and uh wow yeah I was a trumpet player
and yeah so I uh answered the call to go
on the road with a band I quit school
did that for several years and have been
in music business in one form or the
other most of my life and now and now
you're a journalist well yeah I've been
writing on the side you know that was
always kind of my hobby and then it
became my side hustle and that sort of
thing and then once uh you know AOL
became Myspace and Myspace became
Facebook and Facebook became a Blog and
now that has all become Blaze media
that's who I work for now and one of the
big stories that we've been covering
quite a bit is that uh for your coverage
of January 6 as a journalist as one of
the most I mean anybody looked at you
they're like oh that guy's a journalist
right threat to lock you up yeah I mean
of like you're sitting there wearing the
suit on the Blaze and I'm like they
could have some fat dude in a T-shirt
and you're going to be like is he a
journalist or like what does he do that
guy in the suit with the glasses like oh
he looks like a journalist but you know
what I did not look like a journalist on
January 6th because see I had I had a
David Bowie tribute act at the
time and and because it was the the the
co lockdowns I decided that I was going
to change my Bowie look and so I was
actually growing my hair out during that
time so as I'm walking through the
capital on the CCTV cameras I have this
long man coming out of the back my ball
cap they're threatening to lock you up
yeah because you were reporting on
January 6 there there are uh uh several
people who media I mean we'll just go
use Oren Shroyer as an example didn't
even go in the building they did lock
him up and so we've covered your story
uh quite a bit uh thanks for joining us
we'll get into the uh the details on
that and we'll see where we have the
updates but uh yeah it's crazy story
yeah it is yeah right on we also have
Hanah Clair rimo hanging out hey I'm
Hannah Rim I'm a writer for cnr.com you
can see all of our news um on Twitter
and Instagram timcast news I'm really
happy to be here Shane's back what's up
I'm happy to be here I'm also a writer
for scanner and the author of tales from
the inverted world where I write about
the uh the thin line between demons and
politicians quite often and the lack
thereof line and there's no more line
like I don't know it's there welcome to
2024 yeah uh also interested to see what
you take on the new uh new Kanye stuff
is maybe we'll get into that I don't
think we will but we should talk about
that otherwise got a lot of takes and we
definitely got to talk about the Taylor
Swift conspiracy theory uh man I've I've
had a lot of people yell at me that the
that the Ravens uh uh Chiefs match was
rigged that the refs were throwing it
the Ravens were throwing it like what is
happening I had I've heard over and over
again that there were like three
instances of pass interference the refs
didn't call on the Chiefs and like just
gave them a free ride or they're just
salty fans I don't know but I'm seeing
all over X people like rigged rigged
rigged and you've got this scenario
where Taylor Swift and Travis Kelce have
this like movie romance going on where
it's boosting all this uh uh all of
these you know revenue and ratings and
everything but there are a lot of people
on the right who think Taylor Swift it's
it's all one big SC off because she's
going to announce support for the
Democrats I think that's wrong I think
if there was going to be a side' be
something different but we will talk
about that because the idea of the NFL
being rigged is very interesting but
we're going to jump to this first story
here from Sky News check this out Biden
faces pivotal moment as he weighs
retaliation for Soldier deaths in Jordan
drone strike the commanderin-chief will
have given a number of options by the
Pentagon but the consequences are far
from certain and could trigger a wider
War sky news says as early as tonight
President Joe Biden will authorize US
military AC in the Middle East it is
likely to be one of the most
consequential decisions of his
presidency at stake The credibility of
American deterrence and the teetering
stability of the region this comes after
three US troops were killed in a drone
attack and 34 were injured CNN reports
that uh we we'll read three US Army
soldiers were killed and more than 30
service members were injured in a drone
attack overnight on a small us Outpost
in Jordan us officials told CNN marking
the first time the US that US troops
have been killed by enemy fire in the
Middle East since since the beginning of
the Gaza War we shall respond President
Joe Biden said while speaking in South
Carolina on Sunday the killing of three
Americans at Tower 22 in Jordan near the
border with Syria is a significant
escalation of an already precarious
situation in the Middle East officials
said the Drone was fired by iran-backed
militants and appeared to come from
Syria it is still being determined which
militia group specifically is
responsible and of course we're already
seeing the warmongers in Washington DC
say strike Iran now with the reporting
that Joe B
will be authorizing some form of
retaliation tonight many are speculating
this could kick off World War I I also
okay I think it's fair to to to to state
that the problem we have here and the
the difficulty with this kind of
commentary is that you have dozens of
world leaders saying either World War
III is starting has already started or
is about to start then you have constant
tit forat escalations and you and we
just don't know I mean we're in the
thick of it we can't tell we can't see
the forest we're inside of it this could
be the shot her around the world moment
but I don't think we would know until
well into any kind of actual War I do
believe however if Joe Biden does order
any kind of retaliation on on Iran
directly then it's F I think it's fair
to say at that point everything's going
to kick off Domino's one after another
so if there is action taken against Iran
in some capacity and then this ropes in
the other other countries in the bricks
we may 6 months down the line be like
okay we're in World War II history books
will look back and say that moment Joe
Biden order retaliation kicked things
off I got to be honest I'd actually
think that October 7th may be considered
the start if World War III kicks off you
can ignore Ukraine people will say well
there were border conflicts happening
and there was funding of war in Ukraine
Afghanistan collaps and things like that
October 7th was a massive escalation
which results in the houthi rebels
shutting down you know the the Red Sea
basically shutting down shipping which
is now leading to a dramatic escalation
at some point Venezuela can make a move
on Guyana China makes a move on Taiwan
there you go World War I yeah it's
definitely tense geopolitically I mean
that that's the funny thing about the
Ukraine conflict which is that for a
while when this was happening when
Russia was stationing troops along the
border everyone was like we're on the
brink of something we're on the brink of
something and they did shut down trade
and they're all are all kinds of
sanction against Russia and ultimately
we just sorted to learn to live with
this conflict I mean of course the US
government is paying billions of dollars
to to uh support Ukraine and the
American taxpayers are feeling the
effect of that at home but ultimately it
doesn't seem like that was enough to
spark World War III this does seem like
more of a a tension building moment but
maybe we'll feel differently in six
months you know people like Lindsey
Graham they've been wanting Iran forever
they want us inside Iran they want to
slide on in you know occupy that space
and just take it is that why we have a
small contingency in Jordan are they
bait for the warmongers well the other
thing too is that intercept is reporting
we've got troops in Yemen it that the
this is a White House report saying we
did and then in January said actually no
we don't uh we're we're not sure there's
any troops there we we've we there's
been a secret war in Yemen going on for
a decade us has been supplying weapons
even under Trump this is this is this
has been ongoing the question is when
does it come to a point where Russia
China uh or any or any Nation for
instance just finally says yeah no it's
full scale it's
mobilization and would they right like
what who who's going to be the first to
admit that we're in War I feel like no
country wants to be the one to say like
this this is it I think if we get if we
make it to the far future they're going
to have a hard time quantifying World
War III is separated from World War II
and World War I they're going to look at
this all it's like one long sustained
time of violence that's been going on
for uh maybe decades I don't think so I
mean yeah sort of but World War I before
World War I there was the the the the
war starts because of the tensions then
World War II is kind of born out of
consequences from that I mean exactly we
we but look we call World War I and
World War II separate despite the fact
that it's all basically the same
conflict but then I'm thinking like past
that you know we've been kind of doing
these weird scops on each other through
you know the internet and causing all
this turmoil whether the people claiming
it's rigged elections and whatnot I
think they might add those to the idea
of what the war has looked like because
we've entered this new digital space
where the war is on like the digital
Battlefront the the physical Battlefront
we're seeing it escalate now in the way
we think of war in the old school ways
but I think it's been going on kind of
psychologically well that makes me think
of like Tik Tok right I mean when Tik
Tok rolled out everyone realized what
kind of connection it had to the Chinese
government it was sort of this question
of oh what Warfare is being played even
though we are not actively at you know
at War there is there is always uh an
effort to have influence over another
Nation I don't think that ever went away
I I have proof that Tik Tock is war they
banned pop culture crisis I thought you
were to say cuz it created dyy but
that's also true so we have uh there's
another show at Tim cast.com pop culture
crisis hosted by Brett desic and Mary
Morgan uh guests on Friday it's very
similar to timcast IRL and it structure
super chats commentary stories uh
podcast it's live uh every uh Monday
through Monday through Friday 3: to 5
and uh it's it's not a big political
show it's talking about like oh hey this
new movie came out this new video game
the point was to be able to have someone
some way that we could talk about pop
culture issues in this company when
we're mostly talking about news Tik Tock
banned them what was the reason of
community guidelines violations I I I
call Shenanigans I think the real issue
is controlling influence uh of their of
an adversary making sure that the work
we do can't expand Tim cast irel got
banned from from Tik Tock a while ago
and then you know for no no no real
reason given they don't want us to be
able to have influence because the The
Narrative and the message that we share
is good for the United States and the
narrative and message that's on Tik Tok
Dylan malany for instance is destroying
the future Generations I got banned from
Tik Tok right after I posted a video of
me uh on Infowars and I think Alex's
voice just like trips a wire on Tik Tok
and it was like immediately gone I was
like I don't even care I don't even like
Tik Tok like that it was fun sharing
videos of me on Infowars but it was
immediate but Tik Tok has such an
influence culture right now I mean this
is what happened after the October 7th
conflict broke out this was one of the
things that came up that the
conversation that was happening between
mainstream Media or maybe even on let's
say Instagram was different from the
conversation that was happening among
younger gen Z on Tik Tok the the the
difference between the position on being
you know pro-israel versus being pro
Palestine became obvious on social media
more than anywhere else I mean it was
social media and college campuses that
really Led Led people to believe that oh
wait they have conflicting opinions here
we didn't expect it yeah uh are you on
Tik Tok no I banned myself from TI Tok
me the moment it it came into existence
fair play well good yeah but it is still
highly influential did you guys see that
uh Florida is proposing like Banning
Social Media for anyone under 16 with
with parental consent right there's a
couple states that are considering laws
like this so so a kid can go on if the
parents consent to it or you have to
have parental consent if you're if
you're uh if you're a minor if you're
under 18 just like if a kid wants to go
to an adult bookstore he just needs
parental consent right yeah yeah and I
can't remember which state I'll look it
up in a second but one of them you know
you can't just say oh yeah my parents
said it was okay you have to they have
to like sign a document and send it into
the company uh which I find interesting
but again to to your point you know the
challenges that this generation is
facing in terms of you
know trying to understand the challenges
that face their young generation are
very different than the parents who came
out of World War I or the parents who
came out of World War II and I think so
much of that has to do with the digital
age I mean we always see that during
times of threat it you know like after
911 theoretically this was a point where
a lot of people enrolled in enlisted in
the military and there was a sort of
spike in patriotism but that goes away
people have their own questions about
the government's actions this generation
has seen so much tension and conflict
and in fact the fact that they're always
plugged in they're always seeing clips
of awful things all the time could you
inspire them to come together I don't
think so you're saying that social media
created the perfect candidates for drone
operators maybe or just the perfect
candidates to be dis engage because they
are ultimately over stimulated by
everything they see I think it created a
a generation of broken brained people
well that's what the biggest danger is
as my children became teenagers and of
course I could watch on my iPhone what
apps they were downloading you know and
my 14-year-old son downloads Snapchat oh
heck no you know that comes off now you
take it off or I take the phone
instantly it's not that's creepy well it
was it was creepy but you know look th
those guys on his baseball team you know
they're they're sharing photos pictures
and it would would be incredibly easy
for them to make that fatal mistake and
they're branded as a you know sexual
predator for the rest of their life yeah
there been where teenagers share photos
of themselves and it doesn't matter law
doesn't say you or anyone else like the
law just says a photo of a minor done
that's it and so they've had like
14-year-old boys and girls have to
register as sex offenders because they
took pictures of themselves and shared
it but that's the law says or there's
been a couple cases where people will
connect with them effectively catfish
them they'll send like a nude photo or
whatever and then they'll blackmail them
and say like we have this we're going to
ruin your life there was a I think a kid
from Minnesota who killed himself over
this I mean this was this is like a new
danger that I think parents are NE have
never had to contend with because
they're basically inviting strangers
into their home constantly through the
cell phone I want to I want to jump to
the story from the telegraph hosted by
Yahoo news World War III is approaching
fast and too few are willing to admit
why well the article is very interesting
it does mention that there was a drone
attack a drone attack on a us-based near
Jordan but it mentions the core reason
is that authoritarian regimes are
failing Iran Russia for instance
struggling to keep themselves afloat are
going to start making moves I think it's
actually a really good argument faced
with an existential crisis either
economically due to population collapse
or otherwise look a drowning person is
not they thrash about violently and you
know they say when you're going to
rescue someone who's drowning you have
to approach them from from behind
otherwise they drag you down with them
for for these countries that are facing
existential crisis and that includes the
United States there's an option go to
war and we've seen it time and time
again and uh there's a lot of parallels
to everyone's favorite Empire the the
Roman Empire but I want to point out a
few very important things the world
socialist website you know we love them
they report British Army Chief issues
call for conscription and of uh and
whole of n Nation mobilization for war
it's not just Britain Sweden has issued
a call for their sta uh for their
citizens to prepare for war and there
have been reports that people have begun
signing up to be conscripted so in
Sweden they have a system where you f a
questionnaire and determine whether or
not you will be forced to join the war
effort France 24 says Sweden's call for
population to prepare for war Sparks
panic and criticism now I don't consider
the world socialist website to be all
that credible but here's the interesting
thing I believe conscription is the
appropriate word based on the facts
corporate news doesn't want to say
conscription because of what it means to
the average person so of course the
times.co.uk says UK must train citizens
for war with Russia says Army
Chief let me just let me just try that
one for you again UK must train citizens
for war with Russia in other words
citizens should prepare to be
conscripted into war the times doesn't
want to say it corporate press doesn't
want to publicly State we will conscript
you and force you to go to war because
that is never popular and I believe if
all the big Outlets said right now
Sweden and the UK have issued calls for
conscription then there would be a major
push against escalation escal escalation
to stop the war so they want to keep
that out of side out of mind but in the
end for those that are here in the
United States if Joe Biden decides
tonight to uh issue a retaliatory strike
on say the coast of Iran or something on
specific targets and he says for too
long Iran has been supplying the houthi
rebels and other militia groups in Iraq
and Syria and this is now resulted in
the death of three American citizens
America will retaliate we will not back
down if he strikes Iran and Iran says
we're going to war and then calls in
their allies and this escalates
dramatically do not be surprised if they
start sending out draft orders I have
unfortunately a son of draft age and
when I say unfortunately I don't it's
not unfortunate I have a son I like son
it's unfortunate that he is draft age
and it is it is as a father not
something that I want to see happening
obviously but in my entire life though
I've always grown up always thinking
that if we're attacked if our assets are
attacked overseas that we must retaliate
the problem today is I don't believe
anything anymore I don't believe
anything I mean and and and when we
start we start talking about
conscription in Sweden or or especially
in the UK it's like Orwell spinning
around going I Told You So Told You So I
love I love my father but I remember
that one of the first big fights we had
I was maybe 11 or 12 we were watching
some war footage on TV and I told him uh
I will never be drafted they'll draft
they'll try and I'll will never fight
those Wars I don't know just felt
inherent to my soul he he got really mad
like how dare you not want to protect
your country and stuff but my dad buys
into a lot of like the corporate press
although watching Fox 5 and stuff he
buys into the that whole you know
Narrative of patriotism and he's from an
older generation and I get it and I get
why he was mad I always thought about
that fight but I I believe a double down
on that feeling I had then no more now
more but you know what it's sad isn't it
that there used to be a generation of
people who said I believe in my country
wholeheartedly I will fight for them but
the problem is we have seen time time
again the military-industrial complex
and special interests send young men
mostly men off to die for no reason
other than their bottom line yeah and I
and I should add to that because of what
Tim just said I grew up next to a
military base seeing basically people
who are my surrogate brothers and
sisters older brothers and sisters who
were Cadets come back with no limbs
going to die for Wars that made no sense
you know so I was the world I was born
up into and it made no absolutely no
sense yeah this is the conversation my
family had when my brother enlisted and
when he he deployed to Afghanistan with
the Marine Corps was like but why are we
here like you know I respect that that
was the path he thought was right for
him and you know everything else but
also is this the the the operation that
I think is most value for your time not
to mention all the risk but all all
service members families are going to
worry about the risk it was like we
don't even need to be here yeah and
you're going anyways yeah risk is
important and we should be you know the
military to some degree can be important
uh but what has become the the
industrial complex that eisenh how are
warned about we are living in that
horrible nightmare right now if we can't
clearly Define that that the answer to
that question why are we here why are we
going that's why we have to have
Congress make these decisions and not
unilaterally made by one decrepit old uh
scile man or whoever's controlling wow I
usually call him a reanimated corpse
you're very very nice to sorry well it's
because I'm much closer to his age than
you are you you are doing way better
than that man is man I put in quotes
that's the thing too Trump and Biden are
not so far off in age and there's
obviously a huge difference between I
mean there are other politicians that
are close to bid age and he is just not
doing well at a certain point you have
to just you feel unkind being like you
are falling apart sir but you really are
we we got a funny Super Chat Mory says
jenz is not fighting for this country
LOLOL here's a Here's a thought excuse
me sir I noticed that you just illegally
crossed the border would you like to be
a citizen of this country here's a gun
we're sending you to Ukraine the
likelihood I think is is actually very
fairly great in the event of a major war
that the US look it used to be I love I
love the history of of
rifling there used to be oh I love the
story of like The Last Samurai in Japan
they were considered high ranking high
class High status trained Warriors and
then we bring them rifles and we're like
you don't need to train anybody you just
hand it to them you tell him to point
and shoot and all of a sudden the
samurai are considered the much much
less important you don't need to train
someone from birth to be a fighter
anymore when you can hand a gun to
somebody yeah so I don't think people
realize that with with all these
migrants coming through the Border you
doesn't care at all if they're like if
we can bring in six million people every
all the people on the right keep saying
military age males yeah congratulations
the US government says we got 6 million
military age males and will'll tell them
you have no choice you are fighting on
our behalf the question is is what
direction are they going to point the
gun doesn't matter literally literally
does not matter you you you you just
drop Six you you start transporting
these people in Mass to an enemy nation
and it's bedum for that country no
matter what I mean you look at what's
happening in the United States because
of it these people sleeping in airports
the conflict the cast this is not even
conflict it's just them literally being
there causing problems you look at the
United States saying we're going to give
you weapons you win that war you're a c
c citizen of the United States a bunch
are going to say you got it boss but
even if they don't just sending them
over to Iran or whatever it's going to
cause chaos sounds like the Roman Empire
to me yeah and to me the question is
like if they are then back here and
they're like yes thank you government
you gave me my citizenship and I can
fire a gun and they're like now attack
fellow citizens because we said so the
loyalty is concerned me I actually
thought you going to go a different
direction which is like I would be fine
to send our military to our Southern
border to defend it I don't know why go
other places I think the good news here
is uh uh if we do send a bunch of these
criminal aliens in the United States and
say you can be a citizen if you go fight
in Iran or whatever the good news is the
US doesn't keep its promise to its
veterans so once they come back they'll
be completely discarded and the right
won't have to worry about them becoming
citizens this is very Grim cast today
we're very Grim
cast yeah well you know it's hard not to
be when you're seeing this stuff in the
news you know what seeing this this
corpse about to announce more war it's
terrible hey no Mean Tweets that's right
thank God thank God I I just keep they
weren't even really that mean come on I
just keep thinking about have something
to look forward to every day I love that
you see the journalist when they were
like since Trump when when Trump uh when
Biden wins the White House they're like
I used to have to wake up at 3: in the
morning for my phone buzzing a tweet
from Donald Trump and my editors like
you have to write it up now and they're
like now he's gone and we don't or he
got banned we don't have to worry about
it anymore and it's it's finally I'm
relaxing just good old war that's all we
got to write about we just have war no
no tweets at and I see these news these
news items and I think about the way
Biden talks and just how weak he is and
I'm afraid that this Administration is
going to want to overcompensate for his
weakness by doing something real crazy
uh in the next few days CU who knows was
going to hard hard on Iran you know
dropping lots of bombs just making the
people know this is why you should vote
for me I'm a strong man Joe Biden has
never said once in his life unless he
plagiarize it from someone else
obviously but I just seeing all of that
I I I am like having flashbacks to um
the day they announced Biden winning and
all the people in New York City dancing
in the streets and popping champagne I
see Stephen Pinker dancing in his living
room on how happy he is and this is what
they got I think we will absolutely have
some serious mobilization this year I
don't know if I would call it World War
II I mean whatever you know World War I
is trending on Twitter and people are
keep keep saying that this move by Biden
could trigger it and there's there's
smarter and more prominent political
figures than me around the world saying
we're already in it especially because
of this fine but I I got to say it's an
election year Joe Biden's in
trouble I would not be surprised if we
go to war with Iran I I think it's in
fact I think it's greater than chance
does wartime presidents get reelected
yeah and and I wonder if that could
backfire on Joe Biden but
I think it outside of whether or not
Biden could get reelected the the Deep
State intelligence agencies and the
military military-- industrial complex
are saying if Donald Trump gets elected
we ain't getting our war go to war now
then even if Trump wins he can't back us
out but how bad does this world war have
to be before it's a greater threat to
our democracy than was January 6 I'm
sorry nothing on Earth could ever be
more of a threat than January 6 I don't
even know why you 10 911s yeah yeah it
was all of them unbelievable no and
that's a great point of like reading
these articles where that the US the UK
must train citizens for war how they can
downplay anything but also inflate like
something like January 6 into the worst
you know the way the politicians talk
about it it's it's dday it's Pearl
Harbor it's 911 uh but that's what they
do these are the tricks they play you
know the the death of language this is
what they constantly do it's it's it's
actually really scary because people so
many people still buy into it that's
exactly right yeah do you think people
will will shift their opinion on Biden
if he were to take us into war do you
think that could help him get
reelected every single time we have this
situation with a president that's what
we expect is going to happen that's
where the you know the whole Wag the Dog
idea came from and I I just don't know
that first of all I don't know that
Biden is going to be there anyway I you
know I don't know what the I don't know
what the round table here uh consensus
is I'm saying he's not making it I don't
think because he's not going to make it
healthwise or they're going to pull him
oh he's they're going to pull him
they're going to have to pull him they
have no choice I mean just watch him
this past weekend he can't find his way
anywhere any longer all the signs are
there my father passed away as a result
of Alzheimer's and you know and I I'm
watching this unfold you know what we
saw in my own family so it's not going
to happen he's not going to be there but
whoever's pulling his puppet strings
maybe that's what they need is World War
III yeah yeah I think it's I think it's
possible who's pulling puppet strings I
think their hope is look when uh when we
have Trump no new Wars timeline for
withdrawal Joe Biden gets in what's the
first thing he does revers his course we
get more troops we get Syria uh troops
in Syria being bolstered and whoever
remembers us declaring war on Syria just
what when when was that when did we
deploy I don't think we ever declare war
on anything anymore we get war in
Ukraine we get escalation with China
we've got strike us strike groups moving
through the straight of Taiwan you've
got Venezuela and Guyana it is bubbling
up and the the military
military-industrial complex guys are are
are
salivating but they may be thinking you
know Joe can't win Nikki Haley's in
their back pocket she says she's going
to stay here until super Tuesday I could
not believe it I couldn't believe it I'm
I'm like we got a live event we're
planning in Virginia for super Tuesday
and I said let's be real it's not going
to be a super Tuesday I don't know what
it'll be and then she comes out and
she's like I'm not backing out until at
least then it's like okay lady but
that's their plan you got to get some
kind of warmongers up there but if they
can't win they'll take their consolation
prize war with Iran before Trump gets in
and there's nothing anyone we you can't
stop it Joe Biden's the president
republicans in Congress won't do
anything so literally the best course of
action is you vote for Trump and then
hope he can wind things down as quickly
as possible when he becomes president
they're going to pull Biden the
Democrats and then replace him with uh
Nikki Haley that's what they're goingon
to do I'd be surprised I wouldn't be
surprised how funny would that be that
would be funny I don't think she would
actually do it um she sounds but a lot
like them it'll be interesting to see I
mean this is what I'm so interested with
Joe Mansion right now because he said
I'm not going to run for uh Senate again
in West Virginia and he's been in since
2010 which the other fact of this that I
love is that he got nominated or
appointed to the Senate after uh Senator
Robert bird died in office at 96 after
being in office for 51 years I mean the
West Virginia senate seat has like just
basically never been available in
American history uh but he his all
everything he's saying I mean he just
had this interview with CNN saying the
White House is controlled by far
far-left people and he said this a
couple times about Biden and so there
same with um Dean Phillips all of his
stuff if you look at his bio that he has
on his official um Congressional website
right now is like I am a moderate so
there is this movement within the party
to say like we are actually not like
them please don't lump Us in with the
rest of them yeah let's let's talk about
the conspiracy theory that says Joe
Biden will get reelected with the help
of Taylor Swift did you guys see that
Baltimore Sun said Taylor Swift should
be the
VP yes no yeah I should actually pull
that one up oh The Baltimore Sun she's
very very busy right now I don't think
she could actually Baltimore Sun wrote
that after the Ravens lost check us out
that's very disloyal The Baltimore Sun
forget kamla Harris put Taylor Swift on
Joe Biden's ticket read her commentary
so she stops coming to football games
and they said that people are excited
about the Ravens and the Baltimore Sun
is excited because Taylor Swift might
come to Baltimore to watch the game did
some Googling blah blah blah she will be
35 years old on December 13th 20124 her
net worth is 1.1 billion she can afford
to take uh take what for her would be a
volunteer job
yada yada yada yada okay for sure for
sure right now you've got two big
conspiracy theories that are kind of
overlapping with each other the uh
Kansas City Chiefs beat the uh Baltimore
Ravens everybody out here is pissed off
we're in Maryland so everybody out
here's Ravens fans and they're losing it
they're saying the refs were not making
they're making bad calls they weren't
calling out pass interference it's BS
they're pissed but you know that's
sports right well the conspiracy theory
is Taylor Swift and Travis Kelce it it
is a it's a
by I'm assuming the Democrats in the
Deep State I guess so that at the Super
Bowl she can endorse the Democratic
party and tell her to go vote is is is
that that's that that's basically what
the SC plan is I guess that's her Arc
she she's been slowly getting into
politics over the last few years yeah I
mean she endorsed Biden in 2020 but the
thing is she's not very helpful right
now she's literally on the intern she's
about to start the international leg of
her tour it's not like she's it's very
unlikely she's just going to drop in at
Biden can't campaign stops if Biden's
even there himself I think this is a s
up I think that's a fact in what way do
you think that two PR people got
together and said Hey Taylor Swift would
you like to do a celebrity relationship
like we've done with insert every other
celebrity it'll make us a bunch of money
and she was like sounds good so it it's
a s up in the sense I'm being somewhat
factious but I love when the left's
going to take that one out of context
and my point is that this happens all
the time celebrity publicists say who
can we put together the NF was like
that'd be great we'd love to have Taylor
at the games how much will this cost
Taylor's people are like look you show
up to a bunch of games you hang out with
your friends you do this fake
relationship everybody makes hundreds of
millions of dollars the ratings are
going to Skyrocket for the NFL and
there's a lot of money be made with the
Super Bowl you know how much ads cost we
bring in those ratings there's going to
be a ton of money they offer her a bunch
of money I think it's more likely that
she's just doing stupid publicist
nonsense that being said I think the
more plausible conspiracy theory is that
ratings for the Super Bowl have been in
Decline uh a US cultural uh homogeneity
has has gone I mean we used to have like
yeah super bow everybody watched
everybody watched Big Bang Theory now
nobody does and so there's this play
like we're going to create this romance
Love Story travison Taylor and he's
going to propose to her or something big
at the Super Bowl and if that's the case
all the people claiming that the game
was rigged because the the Ravens seem
to have thrown the match or that the
refs weren't calling it properly it's
because the Chiefs are going to win
Taylor Swift and and they're going to
have their moviees romance and he and
Travis uh uh proposes to her or
something and what makes the most sense
is it's it's publicity it's marketing
that's is Kelsey part of the C up or is
he being sced
so in the literal in the literal sense
of what I think is going on uh Travis
and Taylor are engaged in a publicity
stunt that's it look look look I just
want to stress this sorry man 10 of
these happen per year publicists will be
like Jennifer Aniston and insert
celebrity do you guys want to be seen
together at the club and we'll get a
bunch of press generated about you so I
look at this and I see it as no
different what they started dating what
at the beginning of the season is that
July in July I don't know when football
season starts I'll be honest isn't isn't
that the right before the beginning of
the season I don't training camp I feel
weird cuz I'm typically the guy who
thinks most things are scops but this
one so it's weird that we've had this
rooll reversal but like to me this this
just seems like one of those or organic
things of her being a victim of
propaganda becoming this like political
activist over the last few years we've
seen her crying in that in that
documentary she made about abortion I
but she barely is she barely is until
and the only like real uh legislative
issue I've seen her get behind is
anti-stalking laws which seems very
applicable to her life uh but sorry I
don't want to cut you off no I just
think like and I also know these
publicity stts do happen I also know
there's there's history of things like
the World Series being rigged so these
things are all plausible we say these
things people might think we sound crazy
there's there's history there's evidence
of these things happening with her I
just feel like she's such a victim of
the ideology that she's a part of and
and the News sheet the news diet see I I
I completely disagree can how many
instances can you name of Taylor Swift
doing political activism I think of that
documentary I think of in private one
time she was talking with her parents
about how she wanted to help Biden the
only time I can think of it actively
other than the time she like held up
those Biden 2020 cookies was when she
campaigned for uh was Mar not Marsh
black in Tennessee and one of the issues
she got specifically behind was anti-
stocking laws like support of Mara I I'm
going to look it up because I don't want
to say the wrong thing I doubt it was an
an suppor of Martial blackborne I
thought it was about abortion I'll tell
you not abortion it was anti-stalking
for sure what really grinds my gears on
this whole thing about everybody
claiming she's a Democrat scop is that
she posted on Instagram that the Soros
family robbed her yes and I'm like my
friends my brothers when Taylor Swift
says Soros bad you go Taylor is so right
and you go to all of her fans and you
like can you believe what the sorosis
did to Taylor yes they're bad and then
and then what you do is when they're
like yeah that is bad you go now look at
this article about George S and
everything else he does and they're
going to be like wow those are bad
people she primed an entire generation
to be aware of and angry with the
soros's and for some reason there are
conservatives held bent on pushing the
narrative that despite the fact she
publicly complained she was robbed by
them she's secretly working for them no
if she's a s up my think my thought is
that she's actually unintentionally a s
up for the country's pr- natalist
movement I love all those articles that
are like if they get engaged this summer
there will be a baby boom because all of
these girls will look at their
boyfriends and say but where's my ring
we need to have children immediately
like when Taylor Swift declares that it
is time because I mean what's
interesting about her tour right now is
it's the eras to right she's giving a
little bit of music from everything
she's put out so she is sort of cap
stoning her career she's got this
attractive new boyfriend she could push
off the coast have some kids Inspire
women around her I don't think it's a
Democrat thing I think it's a pro
natalist I'm actually going to combine
what you both are saying and I'm
actually going to say screw what I was
saying earlier about her not being a
scop and actually she's positioning
herself to become the new Soros that's
after that Aros is over she becomes SOS
what what if the real the real war
that's happening is that China through
apps like Tik Tok and social media have
been manipulating digital platforms to
make young people sterilize themselves
get abortions and push all this
and the real scop is as you described
getting Taylor Swift to have this moves
romance relationship at the Super Bowl
then announced she's having babies to
get all the young girls to try and be
wives and have babies and reignite
America look I'm love with you guys I've
had this you someone can go into the
archives of Pop Culture crisis I gave
this Theory a long time ago because when
she broke up with her other boyfriend of
six years which by the way that's too
long to date uh well I'm sorry it just
is she would write these lyrics about
how like she wants to be married she
wants to have a child whatever else and
then they broke up and so I honestly
think she's 34 years old she is ready to
settle down she's at the Capone of her
career she is going to lead our
country's uh Rising birth rates and I
think we should all thank her for that
but let's going back to this big thing
where everyone's claiming she's going to
endorse Democrats they're saying it
frustrates me but this a lot of
conservatives are like she's secretly
working for Soros she's going to endorse
Joe Biden out the Democrats win let me
show you some numbers to assuage your
fears a Taylor Swift Instagram post
helped drive a surge in voter
registration from September 22nd 2023 I
saw a post by that guy what's Brian
Tyler Cohen or whatever his name is I
know they love playing these these weird
games he said vote voter.org uh saw
150,000 people visit the site and a
115% increase in 18-year-old voters the
wild thing about it is first the 115,000
people 150,000 people showing up on that
day is is relative to nothing he didn't
say it was an increase or a decrease
it's quite literally just their standard
traffic check this out from NPR they say
when Taylor Swift speaks her fans listen
no they don't that's actually fake news
on Tuesday Morning the singer posted a
short message on Instagram encouraging
her 272 million followers to register to
vote afterward the website she directed
her fans to the nonpartisan nonprofit
vote.org recorded more than 35,000
registrations according to the
organization they say
the 35,000 and you notice how there's
this like muck in the in the middle this
this pattern you scroll down the
35,2 52 new registrations on National
voter registration day were the most
since 2020 the organization said and a
23% jump over last year do you know what
that means the most we can attribute to
Taylor Swift's post is
8,17 voters she's got 27 72 million
followers they're not all American but
I'd have to estimate more than half are
well maybe even not about 272 million
yeah she's probably got 100 million
followers I think half is an easy thing
to half yeah because she's an American
personality but with massive worldwide
appeal even 100 million half of those
are probably already registered to vote
so let's say 50 million unregistered
let's let's you know what I'm sorry
let's be as Fair as possible let's say
only 50 million of our followers are
American half are unregistered 2 5
million she got 8,000 people to register
I'm I'm sorry she could not get people
to sign up for a website for free and
everyone's like she's going to endorse
the Democrats yo I ain't worried about
it at all when when when uh Brian Tyler
or whatever his name is tweeted this I
checked the numbers and the fascinating
thing is when it said a 115% increase in
18-year-old voters that number was like
17 it was like a remarkably small number
increase and it's like it was a 72%
increase from 2019 and 15 from last year
and I'm like wait a minute that means
even less people registered the year
before how many people has Scott
Pressler personally register in
comparison who was more effective
Taylor no question substantially more
than Taylor Swift I would doubt it
easily I would doubt it I uh much like
uh modern feminism being demeaning to
women this idea that Taylor could change
a woman's vote is weird because I also
wonder how many conservative women are
fans of Taylor and they can separate you
know her politics with her art
do you know what what a weird idea right
can you correlate the apparent
disinterest and her fans and her
politics to her fans taste in music
guarante a l i I guarantee Facebook's
algorithm knows your political
persuasion oh God even if you don't say
you're a republican it'll it'll it'll
map it all out for sure so for Taylor
Swift I mean how many on Instagram they
know exactly who's voting and we know
this is true because we had Dr Robert
Epstein on and he said that Facebook
sent Democrats 100% of Democrats got a a
reminder to vote on Election Day only I
what was it 59% of Republicans got the
same message people need to watch that
episode on it's on the culture War it's
a crazy crazy episode like how do you
cheat an election it's really easy
Facebook says all Democrats get reminded
to vote half are Republicans that's it
they're allowed to do it it's free
speech yeah what did they do wrong
because they didn't promise to do
anything right like they don't owe it
you to remind equally we spoke Free
Speech until the FBI comes and sits in
your office Mr Zuckerberg and tells you
what you can and cannot publish on your
platform to be real they're likely going
to his office and saying make sure to
remind all the Democrats yeah yeah what
do you think Taylor twift what do you
think her effect on our nation's
political landscape is well I I've been
in the music business long enough to
understand her connection I get I
actually get it although I'm not a fan I
can look at her I get it I can you're
not a closeted Taylor fan no no not not
not in the least and but I can listen
songs no
that's what I'm going to say if you
listen to the song and you can see and
understand if you if you know anything
about music at all you understand why
that song connects but that doesn't mean
that I like that kind of music it's not
what I listen to i' I've had to sing it
before myself I I like videos of that I
like Taylor Swift's music proba uh not
all of it like some of the songs
actually I'm just like that's not a good
song but uh she's got her hits that I
really do like however I must say if you
uh asked me to choose a
song and uh like put me up between
Taylor Swift and like tulle I'm gonna
pick tulle every single time I I will
put sober on repeat 100 times before I
play a single Taylor Swift song that
being said if Shake It Off comes on or
trouble like I know the words yeah a
little bit like and they're fun songs I
wouldn't choose listen to it but I like
it you know what I mean it's like you
can like some kind of food you don't
order it if you get the choice you get
the choice you're going to go for like a
you know I don't know like a ribey
medium medium rare but if someone gave
you a filet you'd be that's good too no
I've had my own corporate dance band for
23 years we have to play shake it up
right it's mandated by law it is
Corporate dance band is a good name for
a band actually should be let's jump to
this story where it's getting freaky now
everybody thinks there's a scup
conspiracy theory and this one actually
made it substantially worse X block
searches for Taylor Swift after explicit
AI fakes circulate so long story short
on on Twitter SLX a bunch of extremely
graphic images of Taylor Swift started
emerging yo these pictures were crazy
and and and it never ends cuz it take
two seconds to make more but now at a
time when everyone is suggesting that
Taylor Swift is part of a conspiracy to
uh uh rig the Super Bowl so that she can
help the Democrats win in some way this
controversy around AI images happens
which results in one of the biggest
social media Platforms in the world
shutting down your ability to search for
things related to
her this is a media blackout on Taylor
Swift the Twitter X is the news I mean
even even Elon is talking about all
these news Industries news organizations
are collapsing because we get our
information directly from the pipeline
on X now what happens if x says for any
for whatever the amount of time was you
cannot search for Taylor Swift was there
a video circulating of Taylor Swift
accepting money from George Soros I
don't mean that literally I'm making a
joke but like what would if if someone
said I got the scoop I have the proof
right here Taylor Swift accepting money
can't and they post it nobody can find
it yeah this is like the deranged
evolution of the barbar Strand effect
what happened with the photos of her
house back in the day you take something
away makes everyone want to go look at
it and this is like a terrible thing to
want to go look up but I'm I guarantee
you it only made people look it up more
uh but yeah I see that point it's it's
almost like they're Hunter bidening the
the hunter Biden laptop story to the
Taylor Swift story now now um so new X
is just like old Twitter in some regard
is that disappointing did you yeah I
wasn't not surprised though I've seen a
lot of things that this new company does
that are similar to the old one you know
I like it it's it's more fun but uh and
I don't the images are terrible I wish
they'd get rid of all the Nancy Pelosi
nude AI photos honestly as well because
they are damaging my soul and people
they keep popping up in my feet I'm like
why he's not searching for them he
swears yeah yeah imagine I really need
that Pelosi cleavage uh they're going to
clip that man great didn't I see today
that Elon his reaction to this was that
they're going to add up another hundred
employees just to monitor content no I
saw this yeah today oh oh that makes me
so nervous we have we have a super chat
from Trump uh Trump one he says look at
Benny Johnson's X Soros owns her entire
music catalog I'm going to break this
down for you and help you understand
exactly what's going on and why Taylor
Swift is your greatest opportunity
conservatives don't waste it Benny
Johnson posts flashback Taylor Swift let
me play the clip for its 15 seconds and
you can listen to Taylor in her own
words I had the chance to purchase my
music I had the chance to purchase my
music outright my entire catalog was
sold to scooter bronze Ithaca Holdings
in a deal that I'm told was funded by
the Soros family 23 capital and the
carile group what does that mean these
people who believe that she's a Democrat
scop think she is now sold to soros's
family or or funded to sold to someone
by that and that she has to work for
them no no no Taylor Swift publicly
slammed the Soros family on numerous
occasions for stealing her music they
basically outbid her for the rights to
her own song to her own Master
recordings she got mad because the the
amount they were trying to spend in the
songs was not actually worth what the
songs could generate so she was losing
all of the work she had did for years
she again publicly slams them then says
I'm I own the artistic composition but
they bought the master ERS I will
re-record all of my music to sync
soros's $300 million investment one of
the most epic smackdowns of the Soros
family let me stress it was something
like $300 million and by her going out
and re-recording the Masters she ripped
that investment from them to zero while
publicly calling them out the
opportunity here for anybody who
actually looked at this and paying
attention is you've got an army of
teenage girls who love Taylor and when
she slams Sora
you go to them and like if you're a
kadad and your daughter loves Taylor
Swift you can go to go to your daughter
and say what happened did you what was
Taylor Swift talking about with with the
Soros family taking her music from her
and and they're going to be like yeah
because they wanted to try and make
money off it and then Taylor had to
record everything and then you as the
dad can connect with your daughter and
go that's dirty they why would they do
that to Taylor man those Soros people
sure are bad this go this is the
argument that people are making right
now like all see these posts from dads
being like I saw this video of this dad
was like his young girls like maybe like
you know two five and seven or something
and they're all cheering watching the
Super Bowl or the Chiefs game because
Taylor Swift is there and they're like
wow so exciting Taylor Swift is
organically driving women to like bond
with their dads and to get into football
whatever else like conservative dads
could do this too they could use George
showers they could talk about these
things they'd probably be pretty
interesting conversations about
copyright law and like intellectual
property they're just at the s for
whatever reason deciding like no we
can't talk about this cuz Taylor Swift
endorsed Joe Biden one time she she
endorsed Joe Biden she's in the
documentary saying she's a Democrat all
that stuff of course Hollywood is this
is what they do big donors big companies
they go to celebrities and they say
you're on our side or else in this
instance they ripped her off they they
they bought her music out from
underneath her in a in a dirty move and
she her statement was something like I
hope it was worth it because two things
the amount of money they bought the
music for it the music recordings would
not generate that much money so she
couldn't pay it she's like I'd have to
spend a third of my net worth to buy the
rights to my music and I would never
make that money back but she then
re-recorded everything re re-released
those albums and now no one will ever
care about whatever the Soros family
bought so you can criticize her for
being a Democrat all day and night but I
am flabbergasted by the conservatives
who keep pushing the fake narrative the
lie I don't get it I seriously someone
spell it out for me why they keep lying
and trying to make it seem like she's
working for George Soros i i i i i
there's nothing I don't get it I can't I
can't answer that question but I mean
notwithstanding the um uh the loss of
opportunity that conservatives or
Republicans had uh by by what she did by
coming out against sorus speaking ill of
him it doesn't matter ultimately at the
end of the day another oligarch was
going to buy her music anyway because
the mob has always owned the music
industry and ultimately they own the
contract I'm I'm sorry this is the SC up
like guys if there's a SC up the up is
sock puppet accounts on social media
posting things like this George Soros
with Taylor Swift on puppet strings I
get it it's actually not a completely
unfair thing but how can you guarantee
to sever any opportunity someone had to
actually have a celebrity on your side
it's this I I this is so backwards
Taylor Swift publicly criticizes Soros
on numerous occasions and for some
reason the entire wave of social media
posts from the right is that she's
working for him I'm like that's a s up
right there I don't know who's doing it
or what but I I'm sorry if I'm going to
believe a conspiracy theory it's that
deep State whoever or whatever it is you
guys think we're like oh no oh no Taylor
Swift came out against George Soros we
need control of this quick pretend to be
Maga and claim she's working for Soros
and and it worked okay but I also have
like five layers of tinfoil hats on at
all times and I can be like well Soros
told her you got to come out publicly
against me so then people don't don't
buy the I would agree with that if the
narrative was she was against Sor right
but it's not all these conservatives
just keep hammering that claim over and
over again and I'm like that's weird
because imagine if conservatives dads
were able to go to their daughters and
say I I agree with you I support you I
can't believe they would do this to
Taylor Swift and now you're going to
have a dad so here's what happens these
these teenage girls are watching the
Super Bowl and the dad is sitting there
going she works for George Soros and the
girls are going uh Dad she hates Soros
no she works for him creating a divide
between the conservative dads and their
daughters cuz the dads believe something
that's wrong and I don't know why keep
people keep pushing it and then they
don't have children and also our birth
our teenage pregnancies go up and it
ruins everything conservative dads this
is your moment it's almost like Q
fractured into a billion different
conspiracy theories and now people are
just everything is a conspiracy which I
understand because lots of things are
conspiracy theories and the government
does really dark deranged things all the
time secretly um but yeah this doesn't
feel that way it's just we have we're
such a low trust Society right you can't
trust anything that comes out we can't
even look at Taylor Swift dating like
the hunky football player be like wow
good for her but it's also anything that
comes out of Hollywood I distrust yeah I
think you made a good point about her
being 34 like here here's a conspiracy
theory for you Taylor Swift is about to
hit the
wall also what else is she gonna do
right like she is already the highest
paid female musician she was one of the
youngest people to win all kinds of
accolades like where does she go from
here the thing that she doesn't have in
her life is a she has like a family like
a a mom and a dad or whatever but like
she doesn't have her own kids her best
friend is Blake Lively who has four kids
I think with Ryan Reynolds like you guys
I you're all men this I don't even know
who people are this is the thing I 100
married to R Reynolds I know Ron
Reynolds his wife they have lots of kids
together so they'll adopt Taylor no she
I think she is like one of their I don't
know I don't know whatever but like the
thing is I think she's one of their like
God Parents or something but like I
think ultimately Taylor Swift is so
interesting to me because she represents
this this thing that all women were
supposed to do which is to rise the top
and to be mad at men because they take
their career away even though they're
clearly succeeding where men could never
succeed I'm sorry there's just no male
pop star that has this kind of attention
over female fans and yet ultimately she
gets out of this six-year relationship
she's singing constantly about wanting
to start a family and get married and
now she's with this other guy who's been
on his podcast saying yes I want to be
married he does his podcast with his
brother who's happily married to like
his college sweetheart with multiple
children like this is the rise of a
pronatalist pro- family movement and
conservatives just need to embrace it
stop making steal it or steal it steal
co-opt it come on exactly if if if the
truth is that Taylor Swift is a big scop
and she's like GNA go democr whatever
the narrative from the right needs to be
to take control of the river that that
massive Force coming at you and divert
it by instead of attacking the thing
things she does with Democrats support
the things she's doing like I love that
Taylor says she wants to have a family
she's right and Travis saying the same
thing how wholesome I I actually am
really inspired she doesn't like George
SOS what a good person make that the
focal point right also I've been
thinking I'm not a fan of hers I can
appreciate some songs but like the work
ethic that went into re-recording
everything is crazy like didn't Michael
Jackson buy all the Beatles music C
that's the last time I cared about who
bought who catalog was when Jackson
bought all of the Beatles tell that
story really quick isn't like mcart
didn't McCartney tell Jackson you should
own catalog music catalog and then
Jackson turned around and bought the
Beet he actually he actually outbid
McCartney for his own songs but but but
see here's the difference between what
we're talking about now and then there
was no politics involved in that at all
now everything is shaded by politics
totally agree we can't get away from it
nope man it's just it's just Taylor
Swift pulled off what may be one of the
biggest Fus to the Soros family ever
they bought music for for something I I
think it was three them can you fact
check me on this I think it was was $300
million and then by her re-recording it
all she ripped $300 million out of their
pockets man that's because she their
their investment becomes zero so they
bought the Masters not the publishing so
she owns the artist composition right
which means the songs core the the the
recordings she did were bought by Soros
and the Carl group and these other
investors by re-recording it that
investment was worthless now right just
absolutely worthless and he sold it for
close for it's never been disclosed but
they believe it's north of $300 million
by he you mean scooter BR scoter Bron to
yep and wow she was saying something
like it's not worth it imagine all of
those songs on streaming platforms how
much money will it generate nowhere near
that much in their lifetime that means
she would have to in like it it may have
been that they knew Taylor wanted her
career this is her her life's work and
they were probably thinking like you're
a billionaire if you want it we're going
to drive the price up to 300 million
you'll never make that money back it's
ours was she smart enough to realize it
wasn't worth it yes and okay well now
and here's the thing maybe that
inverting Swifty phant this may have
been the move to try and control her
basically you're a high-profile
celebrity you work for us now or we will
own your life's work and you can do
nothing about it instead she goes I will
re-record every single song and you will
get nothing you know who told her to do
that Kelly Clarkson really yeah I'm just
telling you it's like a fascinating wave
of characters wouldn't expect see this
is a great way to bridge The Divide
between Kanye and
Taylor it should happen because this is
all Kanye was railing against a year ago
my contracts people owning my stuff this
is what Prince talked about you know and
like this why girls came off the air all
the things that are important she came
out unscathed you know I I don't think
Kanye did let's let's let's jump to
completely away from American pop
culture and go back to Civil War I got
good news for everybody from American
Military news 18,000 border patrol
agents support Texas and blast the Biden
Administration a statement released
Thursday by the nbpc which is the
official unit of over 18,000 Customs and
Border Protection uh employees pushed
back against what the union described as
fake news reports that the border patrol
agents would be arresting Texas National
Guardsman at the border quote Rank and
file BP agents are not going to start
arresting Texas National Guard members
for following their lawful orders that's
fake news the Texas National Guard and
rank and file BP agents work together
and respect each other's jobs period if
National Guard members have lawful
orders then they have to carry out those
orders so this is great uh and I think
it shows the emperor has no clothes Joe
Biden is is impotent here I don't know
that I believe it completely that I like
you know things are always not what they
seem it may be uh that the Customs and
Border Patrol agents are no no no we're
not going to do any of that stuff we're
they're doing lawful orders but behind
the scenes CBP is just saying say this
avoid conflict or the unionist avoid the
conflict but try and keep doing your
job I want to I want to be optimistic
Joe Biden says go fight CBP says we're
we're not going to fight over this Tex
National Guard they're in the right no
conflict we move on I think it's a good
thing because as I've said before the
win condition for the left is a civil
war starting not fighting a Civil War
and winning so I want to give a shout
out to all the you know what I love I
just these leftists who love putting my
name in their YouTube videos and then
arguing something I've never been in
favor of they're like Tim Po's arguing
about Civil War blah blah blah and I was
like I have literally said your win
condition is starting a Civil War and we
want to avoid at all costs so thank you
and have a nice day but yeah I don't
know what you guys think good news uh
yeah I I know when I was with Carri Lake
uh at her Senate announcement she shared
letters uh she read one with me from a
guy who was working border patrol who's
like this place is defunct they're not
running this place properly we need help
I I shared that one letter in the last
carer Lake article I wrote for scan
um so like people obviously are going
against the administration uh they have
to cuz they see just so much fentanyl
pouring over that border uh terrify
wasn't there like some big story where
someone died from uh fentel laced uh pot
recently I didn't see it I can't
remember exactly what the story was I
just know that it came up because
someone was asking me about it and like
how does these things happen I'm like it
sounds like they're trying to kill
people by doing it I believe yeah I
believe they are I'm blanking on who it
was but it's a um famous celebrity son
yeah was the guy from Pawn Stars right
yeah pawn star he said and he blamed he
literally blamed the Border yes uh yeah
absolutely at car Lake's announcement uh
she filled the stage with parents who
lost children to fentanyl in various
ways whether it was like you know and
bring it back to Prince really quick
people forget Prince was on different
pain meds someone gave him a counterfeit
pill that was Fentanyl and that's what
Mac Miller right maill supposedly I'm
not sure if it was fentanyl with MC
Miller or something else but uh I know
if Prince it was it's it's everywhere
prevalent no one's safe not Prince and
not you know the people in these border
towns and the rest of this country Dez
Dickerson who was um a Prince's guitar
player in the revolution he's the guy
that wanted the comicazi headband in
1999 sang some of the song You know the
song well Dez been a good friend of mine
for over 30 years and he told me
absolutely 100% that that Prince that
was an accident this was not something
that Prince did to himself by oh yeah
this was I believe that and they never
caught the person who gave him the
counterfeit right right we know Michael
Jackson was killed by a doctor and he
spent two years in jail but Prince's
whoever gave him the counterfeit drug
that was fentol yeah never MC Miller MC
Miller was fentol and they put whoever
gave it to him in jail as well uh it's
weird I mean I feel like the obvious
answer is close of the Border but people
have been so averse to it for so long
we're really feeling the consequence of
it now I feel like it's a an another
easy attack Vector for China yes pot
laced with fentanyl yeah and then a
bunch of young people die I mean there
there's isn't someone from the Biden
administrating is meeting with a
representative from China this week I'm
pretty sure this happened once before
earlier this year bider met with uh Jing
ping in San Francisco I think and they
were like so tell us that you'll stop uh
because a lot of stuff that goes into
fentol is is manfacturing China and ship
to Mexico and comes across the border
and he was like so please tell us you
you'll stop that and they were like
we'll see we'll think about it we'll
work with you like the fact that we
couldn't even get China to commit to
being like okay fine we'll stop shipping
fent all like we're in a weak position
because we made our border weak and by
the way people fly I mean Chinese people
will fly to uh both South America and to
Canada
to then Traverse into America through
the Border like we're we're we're bad on
both sides right like the the US Mexico
border has been weak for a long time and
we're seeing the effect of it now but I
think it's also important to start
talking about what's happening on the
northern border where they are seeing an
uh an an a rise in illegal Crossings and
especially during this time of year it's
incredibly dangerous for both the the
Border forces that are out there and the
people who are crossing because you can
actually freeze to death right I
appreciate that you bring that up the
Canadian on the cast bringing that up
thank you very much look team Canada is
important too it hangs out there but not
all Canada is Justin Trudeau's Canada I
have watched with my own eyes in real
time fenel being tracked by United
States Department of military private
contractors from China I've actually
seen it on the computer screen being
tracked And yet when it gets to
Mexico somehow it makes it across it's
like some operation Fast and Furious
situation like we know where it is we're
tracking it then it just I me backfires
it's a sincere desire to stop it but
once it arrives in Mexico then it breaks
down from there crazy the cartels are
running those some of those border towns
I mean the amount of fentanyl there's
millions of pounds at one of those
places I forget what the what town it
was maybe near Tucson but it's it's
apocalyptic how much fentanyl's coming
through and the idea that China doesn't
know about this when they have like one
of the most extensive like uh
surveillance states in the world they're
saying oh we don't know where it's
coming from we have no idea who's making
this and also that's just a f no they're
catching at the B so much coming through
real hard time deciding whether I'm more
afraid of what's happening in the Middle
East right now are we going to have
World War III or about what's going on
at the border I'm still struggling
between the two I think we should put
the Border first I mean that's my
personal opinion right like I can't say
everything that's going to happen abroad
but I can say it is crazy to me that we
aren't all like immediately Secore the
Border it's crazy to me that Texas is
saying or the federal government is
saying Texas take that razor wire out so
people swim across the Rio Grand rather
than go through legal Port of Entry
while they're trying to illegally enter
this country like these are things that
are within our control and we're
actively saying but look over there look
over there should we get involved over
there why don't we shut our own door I
mean I've said this before a couple
times on the show we should lock our
door before we say by the way this
neighborhood is dangerous like if the
world's a dangerous place right now why
aren't we showing up resources at home
but to Tim's Point earlier it's because
the military-industrial complex wants to
have the war over there cuz they can
then play with all of their big toys
they can't play with their big toys why
they deploying troops to the border
right I mean maybe it wouldn't give you
the paycheck that it would if you were
engaged internationally but at least
then you would still have some income
coming through not that you should be in
support of the military-industrial
conflict but I'm just saying they could
make money off of anything if they make
it look like it's worth deploying our
troops they just don't right but that
our troops should be at the border
that's exactly where they should be they
shouldn't be over there in Jordan in a
limited deployment of being Canon fodder
for the uh you know the the the Lindsey
grahams and uh you know of the world I'm
I'm afraid you said saying big toys
overseas is going to give some people
really bad ideas of using them on the
border at some point but they won't
because they don't care about the Border
you know like what are they going to do
to these people at some point or or
they're turning on us yeah these are
like our honorary citizens now like
these people that are coming across the
border that are giving like thanksg in
Chicago they're G like Thanksgiving
meals and stuff and they're like you
know just random families and it's like
don't ever try to migrate here legally
which I know your family's had
experience my family had experience with
this like anyone who has had to do it
you guys have to figure it out on your
own but if you come illegally we we'll
give you support the the Border in Yuma
watching the border patrol sit at the at
the wall waiting with luggage tags and
bottles of water and their van to take
the people to HQ where if they have a
number to someone in the states and that
person picks up they will fly you there
for free is is insane totally insane
stuff and watching these individuals
come across and you see the piles of the
wristbands you've seen those and the
different colors see that they they are
the cartel's product and that's what
those wristbands represent and they and
when they reach different transfer
stations they get a new colored
wristband on the way we'll continue to
let the cartel PE treat humans like
products we promote human smuggling by
keeping our border open so that Joe
Biden can say well Trump is the one that
closed the border and I'm the one who
opened it and aren't I a better person
for that when actually you're
encouraging horrible atrocities to H to
happen to you know I'm sure there are
some very desperate people who think
this is the right path forward I think
there are also people who just know I
can make I can have an advantageous life
if I by illegally crossing to America
this whole system is crazy and yet we're
supposed to pretend that Democrats are
supporting something good by saying no
no border restrictions are somehow bad
that seems crazy it's another
overcompensation even though Obama was
the one I believe who had people in
cages they say it was Trump so he's got
to overcompensate for the Trump cage uh
but so by doing that he's just opened
everything up well humans can be a
product here but they're going to be
Canon fodder over there and that's the
that's the conflict that we're looking
at do you feel like during your time
dabbling journalism the conversation
around illegal immigration has changed
very much or do you feel like we're
we're just more Amplified on positions
that parties already held it's more
Amplified and and I'm you know I'm one
of those Libertarians who does not
believe in open borders because we live
in a dangerous world right you know I I
I I have a utopian libertarian ideal I'm
I if I take the test I'm a full-on
Anarchist right except for one thing
that's not the world in which we live
right it's the world we want I wish we
could live in that world but we don't so
my attitude has not changed yeah and and
that I I had that attitude what about
other people who kind of share your
values do you feel like other
Libertarians have moved to more closed
board position some have but you know
the idealistic of those who are you know
purist in some way right right right
let's let's let's talk about what's
going on with uh January 6th and uh your
case we have the story from Real Clear
investigations it's been covered quite a
bit over the past few months this one is
investigative issues independent
journalist receives January 6 grand jury
subpoena Steve says he believes actors
in the Department of Justice seek to
silence him this is back in August since
then you've received notice that they
actually are intending to criminally
charge you and you are a journalist you
uh uh you work for the blaze or you
you're contributor no I I am now a
full-time investigative journalist for
the blaze I officially shut down my
bands and my operations musically and I
am so you you were you were acting as a
journalist on January 6 correct you are
friends with uh many prominent
journalists notably uh Richie mcginness
yes who was uh uh what did he say to you
that it would be insane if they went
after you for working journalism on
January 6 but now they're coming after
you so what's happening well they
actually made the first threat against
me all the way back in November of 21 I
did my my FBI interview in July of 21 so
6 months after January 6th and then or
actually no that was when they first
contacted my attorney and then we did
the interview in October of 21 on
November 17 18 of 21 my attorney got an
email from a assistant us attorney out
of Philadelphia who said your client
that would be me is going to be charged
within the week and that within the week
that was in 2021 yes that would have
been that would have been Thanksgiving
week of 21 that they originally
threatened me with charges we went on a
media and a press offensive instantly
you know press release started doing you
know podcast and TV and radio interviews
and things of that nature and so I that
among other things we think they backed
off they were like you know this guy's
too big of a pain in the butt for us to
deal with so they just moved me to the
bottom of her pile the the assistant us
attorney and and so we didn't hear from
them for 20 months they went away now
for 20 months though I kept waiting for
those red dots in my bedroom window
every morning at 6 o'clock I I I have
people think I'm joking when I say this
I don't have to set an alarm anymore 6
o00 every morning I wake up and I look
for the red dots in my window what do
you mean red dots the the SWAT R lasers
being weapons pointed yeah yeah of
course that's not you know they don't
actually use red dots anymore it's
because it would be at two in the
morning that's why I understand yeah
yeah yeah but but it's it's it's what I
it's it's what I expect or what I'm
fearful of and and I've had that burden
in my gut for that long and so uh 20
months went by and then in August as you
can see from that uh the date on that
article right there by Joe hanaman that
in August I got another call from my
attorney said okay and now we have a uh
grand jury subpoena for you and they're
subpoenaing subpoenaing your work from
January 6 so they wanted my videos which
was completely uh unnecessary because we
not only offered that to them during my
FBI interview you know free of charge so
to speak with as a yes a complimentary
uh service to the FBI but more
importantly it was part of the the
cooperation and then secondarily we
offered it to them yet again uh to the
the uh uh Department of Justice through
exchange with my my attorney there's
nothing to hide there it it didn't
matter I I don't think I was going to I
was going to cause anybody that was
there on January 6 any harm because they
were already on a thousand other videos
anyway so it it really wasn't going to
hurt anybody if I gave them my videos so
that was my thinking anyway at the time
so we get a grand jury subpoena the
problem with a grand jury subpoena is
that they don't grand juries are not
seated for misdemeanor
charges only for felonies it's like okay
crap what are they looking at what are
they going to try to do now what have
they been scheming and concocting for 20
months while they've been silent so we
we complied I I gave them a flash drive
actually I actually confronted my FBI
agent in the parking lot at his field
office with my attorney standing beside
me and I grilled him for about 15
minutes about what were what they were
doing for 20 months what you know what's
going on I don't know I don't know I
said no that's BS you do know because
you're the one that has to write the
statement of facts based upon which the
Department of Justice will then file
charges against me so it's going to be
your recommendations you know and he
wouldn't tell me and so uh another five
months goes by I'm actually sitting in
Thomas massie's office in DC rer
building and I get another text from my
attorney and it's like you know because
when your attorney calls you it's never
good and so I step out into the
hallway and uh he says okay I guess this
is the big day this was on Thursday
December 14th and he said uh they are
asking you to self-surrender in Raleigh
North Carolina uh on Tuesday so this has
been the Tuesday Before Christmas week
of this past year so I uh I took my my
big breath I uh walked
outside and then I tweeted out that it's
happening and within 24 hours you know I
had four and a half million views of
that tweet and then the blaze went into
high gear and there were other media
appearances as well over the next 24
hours within 30 hours by 5:00 close of
business on Friday the 15th of December
my attorney gets another call from the
FBI agent and he says okay we're going
to postpone your selfs surrender until
after Christmas wow all right so now so
my other my lead attorney because I have
six attorneys on this case now and so my
lead attorney then he takes over so he
contacts the new assistant us attorney
because now they they've assigned me to
somebody else during that 30h hour
period they took it away from uh
assistant us attorney Anita Eve out of
Philadelphia and they assigned it to a
guy by the name of Adam Dreer out of DC
so got a new guy Young Gun on the case
and and I guess that's the that's the
kill shot you know the guy he's he's the
he's the specialist right so um the week
between Christmas and January 1st my
lead attorney got on the phone with him
so okay what's what's going on here okay
what right now what he says is that
they're going to delay the selfs
surrender till sometime mid January and
because we know Mr Baker's travel
schedule and what he's doing because I
stay on the road almost fulltime and he
says uh we'll give you seven give him
seven to 10 days notice before he needs
to come in and present
himself uh okay okay I'll pass that
along to my client uh what are the
Charges going to be well um I can't tell
you what what do you mean you can't tell
well I could tell you but we're not
because as soon as I tell you Mr Baker
will twe tweeted
out as is your right though yeah as is
my right now technically he could fall
back on the fact that until an actual
judge or magistrate signs the arrest
warrant there are no charges yeah so you
know well so it's the end of January
what's the what's the latest that's it
oh we haven't heard from them
since I think the shows uh you know you
look at the Trump EEG Carrol case
and there's there's no justice system it
is weaponization of it's remarkable to
me Trump gets Accused by some some
crackpot old woman of a story that's
based off of that that bears striking
striking resemblance to Law and Order
SVU denies it and the denial is
defamation yeah then he he he gets he
gets accused of fraud in New York the
judge issues a summary judgment without
hearing any evidence and says don't
doesn't matter Trump did it now in the
trial to determine the the amount of
Damages and whether or not he falsified
business records all the witnesses are
like oh no Trump was doing business on
the level it's totally fine doesn't
matter we've already said so what we
have here I think it's just it's proof
of they will do whatever they can get
away with and with you you're on the
line you're not some you know you're not
Ben Shapiro no you don't have millions
of followers but you're not nobody
you've got you work in media and a lot
of people are paying attention to your
story if you were like so many of the
other J Sixers who bumbled about
confused
like I'm not talking about the riers I'm
talking about the woman I met who said
she showed up an hour after the riot
doors were open there were no barcades
and she walked around confused and went
home 18 months sentence yeah she does
not have the platform you have as a
journalist and so now you've put them in
this position where they're like we got
to get him but oh man he's too loud this
past Thursday myself and four of my
attorneys in Dallas in De Plaza we did a
press conference interesting CH location
location chosen stand on the little box
in the middle of the street well I made
sure I took uh photos of the ex in the
street but the point being is is that we
did a press conference there and I
actually addressed the point that you
were making right there and I said that
exact thing unfortunately there were so
many that had come before me already and
I'm talking specifically about other
independent journalists who have been
jacked up by the system and they did not
have the coverage of me they didn't have
four you know um great attorneys
standing behind them they didn't have
the power of the bullhorn of the blaze
behind them at the time and they didn't
have the reach so they they were uh
completely overwhelmed by that most of
them having to uh use um appoint trial
you know court appointed lawyers to
defend them that were probably of a
leftist bent to begin with didn't really
care about their case I know of
individuals that have been jammed into
what they call um a uh you know these
these stipulated bench Tri they don't
even know what you know the the the
client doesn't even know what that is
what is that and they try to explain to
them it's a lot simpler it's easier it's
it's going to cost you a lot less money
well basically you're just walking in
and pleading guilty without the
opportunity to present your case or
present any exculpatory or diminishing
you know something that might diminish
your charges or you diminish your um
your sentencing that sort of thing but
specifically to the independent
journalists that have been caught up in
this thing I've watched s uh this is a
this is a great example uh a young guy
Steven horn also from Raleigh North
Carolina we never knew each other before
the January 6 um thing but what ended up
happening to him is this this he was 22
years old on January 6 but he had had a
history of doing journalism since he was
16 including acquiring applying for and
acquiring press passes for various
events that he had covered so when he
goes up to cover that event he actually
tried to acquire a pass he actually
contact attacked Metropolitan PD um they
wouldn't issue him one he went anyway he
had been covering riots and you know the
20 riots and and Raleigh so he installed
inside of his bicycle helmet a hidden
camera so he didn't look like press he
didn't wear press anywhere and so that
he could blend into the crowd so he gets
uh he he gets arrested and he gets the
four basic misdemeanor charges he
decides he's going to do a a jury trial
right so in the process of doing and
putting all this together D in DC yes I
mean Brave kid he's he's going and and
I'll tell you exactly why he decided to
do that there's another reporter by the
name of Luke moglen who submitted his
story to the New Yorker he captured the
famous video of the QQ on Shaman inside
the Senate chamber you know chanting
praying all of that so Luke and um uh
another uh journalist by the name of JD
Rivera from Pensacola they basically
paralleled each other through the
building took the same thing JD ended up
getting eight months in prison wow uh
Luke of course didn't because when Luke
submitted his story to the New Yorker
the title of his story was among the
insurrectionists Y so he had to get out
of jail free card already you know yep
he said Insurrection right right so but
back to Steven horn so Steven horn says
well look I'm going to you know I'm
going to go declare my innocence in
front of a jury and so they file a
motion for Selective prosecution in his
case his his attorneys do and the judge
a Trump appointed judge by the name of
Kelly he would not allow the jury to see
those press badges what what that's
correct how do they how
because yeah wow this disgusting he
might tweet it disgusting so he would
not allow that jury to see these now I
went up to DC to cover that trial I was
there for every minute of that of Steven
Horn's trial and so I I finally reached
a level of frustration one day and you
know I I I ran out into the hallway to
where the the the attorney's room was
and knocked on the door and then one of
them answered the door and I said you
have to present blah blah blah blah blah
and he said we can't what do you mean
you what do you mean you can't it's the
truth about his life about his career
about his desires since he was a kid to
be a journalist we can't talk about it
we're under orders we can't bring that
up and so what they did is the US
attorneys denigrated that kid they
absolutely
completely um made any insinuation that
he was there for any other reason other
than to participate in the riot uh it
was it was completely slammed and they
could not just even show that jury but
you know these were the Press badges he
acquired since he was 16 how what did he
get uh this was a miracle his sentencing
was the day after Reep s
sentencing and that R sentencing sent
shock waves oh got chills here in that
yes wow because he got off so easy with
the slap on the wrist wow so so horn
only got a year probation and a $2,000
fine still too much still too much thank
God and if it had been before EPS very
likely it absolutely because because and
now before EPS was the guy I mentioned
from Pensacola JD Rivera he was actually
the first person from the panhandle of
Florida to be caught up in the drag net
uh early January of of uh 21 and he was
the first one arrested in that part of
the country and he was actually
contracted by a television station from
mobile he shows up at he shows up at
January um uh 6 with his big gear his
big expensive you know shoulder mounted
camera and he's going through there and
going through and and he went through
the same broken window that Luke mulson
wow New Yorker submitted his story to
they both went through the same Broken
Window Luke mulson had his iPhone Luke
mulson said yes I used my phone as a
reporter's notebook and and JD had his
expensive gear so when he gets home and
the and the the the station is all
excited when they're Drive he's driving
home on the 7th they're calling you you
got all this you got all this footage
it's incredible we can't wait to see it
can't wait to get it and then when he
gets home he doesn't hear from them at
all a few days later over 20 agents show
up at his doorstep red dots on his wife
his kids his family you know what ads
crime was he never chanted he never said
USA USA he never uh you know stopped the
steal or or any chant whatsoever he
wasn't wearing all the Trump
paraphernalia that sort of thing his
crime is he had been and had covered and
had been active in the Hispanic or
Latinos for Trump movement prior to that
wow so he gets he goes to a bench trial
so he was smart enough not to you know
to risk a jury but the judge in his case
convicted him and when he was sentenced
he was given eight months in prison he
spent his first two months in solitary
confinement when he gets out of solitary
and he gets into the general population
of this medium security prison in
Georgia the other prisoners uh thought
he was a you know he was some sort of
spy or plan or whatever because his
story is fake it had to be fake because
because misdemeanor defendants are not
sent to this prison so they're all
looking at him like going no hey we're
the pros this is what we do for a living
we go to prison we commit real
crimes misdemeanor defendants do not
come to this prison he said no man this
is so infuriating I feel like you've
seen the face of the military-industrial
complex in terms of how they've grown
out into the media and these people are
like the engineers of the false reality
where like you can tell that story if
you use the right words like we talking
about the headlines earlier but if you
tell it like this we're going to throw
you in jail was was Judge Kelly was he
the one who also acquitted the that guy
on uh for uh trespassing because the cop
waved him in was that was that Kelly no
that wasn't Kelly I forget which judge
that was but uh Kelly was also the guy
over
the do you know what happened to John
Sullivan remember that guy yes I covered
his trial I was there uh I just
interviewed his mom and dad just a
couple weeks ago did he get in trouble I
I I didn't all I saw was that he sold
the stuff to like CNN oh yeah he was he
was convicted on seven counts and then
he um was remanded into custody after
being allowed to sit in a home
confinement for almost three years he
was immediately remanded into custody
and taken off to jail mcf mcfaden yeah
mcfaden ruled that Matthew Martin was
not riding and he was invited in by the
police he yeah because he he made a
reasonable um uh assertion and it was on
video that when he walked in as he's
passing a cop and he he's he kind of you
greeted the cop in a friendly kind of
manner and then the cop kind of patted
him on the shoulder wow the mcfaden said
I you know you you this this is why uh
and and forgive me everyone but this is
why I say Civil War so often The Young
Turks make a living off of ly uh it's
what they do and so in in January of
2022 I think it was I had made a
statement that we were going to start
seeing acquittal because in order for
there to be trespass charges you need to
have asserted uh uh property rights in
the first place meaning if there is a
barrier you cross you are Beyond
trespass we've dealt with this so
typically the law is and the law in
Maryland specifically I don't know DC
laws it's not the same as Maryland but
there's probably a tremendous overlap if
someone walks onto your unguarded
property they have only trespassed if
they have been warned they are
trespassing in the case of the capital
when the barricades are removed and the
doors are open and the cops are holding
them open you cannot claim someone is
trespassing in any traditional legal
sense you would never
win if you put up a sign that says no
trespassing private property or closed
to the public and someone walks past it
they have now trespassed if you put up a
chain Across the Threshold with a sign
saying no trespass and they step over it
in Maryland that's fourth degree
burglary entering crossing a barrier to
enter a property many of these J Sixers
they show up and what do they see
there's no
barricades there's the doors are open
and the police are waving people in I
said we're going to see aitt The Young
Turks this is what they do uh that's why
I gave a shout out on Twitter to Anna
and vosch because vosch does the same
thing they'll take a morsel of an
argument made something like me saying
they're going to uh quit some of these
people on trespass charges and then
apply that to a guy bashing a cop with a
shield or something and say Tim P thinks
a guy who bashed a guy with a shield is
gonna is not going to get charged
because he didn't know there's broken
glass everywhere and he's fighting the
police which is literally not what I
said and so when you have have a a wave
after wave of people falsely believing
these psychotic things they cheer for
the government oppressing beating and
murdering people and the best part is
these are the people who claim to be
activists against the prison systems
while supporting one of the most
egregious violations of human rights in
the United States of Our Generation
people who were walking around DC but
you know you know what the issue is
they're all Trump supporters so it's
fair game if you were a trump supporter
on DC and you showed up to the capital
an hour and a half or two hours after
the riots they're arresting these people
they didn't fight anybody they didn't
break anything they did not trespass and
these people are going to jail if you're
Owen Shroyer and you're at a permitted
rally you got a permit for it but you
yelled something like death to tyrants
you're going to prison because you're
all Trump supporters and then uh uh what
you get is the leftwing media the
leftist media will absolutely lie about
everything that happened for the the
benefit of making money for their
companies I will tell you that I have
had conversations with some of my MSM
colleagues who have of course off the
Record conceded that they some of those
accidental tourists accidental
trespassers just didn't know the DC law
and didn't understand DC and they would
concede that you know they probably got
to the door they saw the line of people
coming in and
they probably thought it was all right
we here in DC though of course we know
how uptight it is and we probably a a
local resident proba I completely
disagree that's what they tell me we
have seen over and over again protesters
storm DC buildings there are protests in
DC every week are they bust
in protesters the the ones that are
storming are those the ones that are
absolutely uh leting organizations will
get Charters activists will show up in
DC and they'll they enter these
buildings and shut them down yeah kav
heing yeah I mean kav hearing is one
example but we had a recent example
where Jafar leftists were protesting
Israel right yeah and and and shutting
things down in DC in these buildings
during Occupy Wall Street occupiers
showed up in DC everybody entered these
buildings and there were thousands of
people stor like I shouldn't say
storming but marching through the Halls
chanting knocking on doors looking for
members of Congress totally fine totally
a okay so when you have hisor precedents
and legal precedents that protesters do
enter these buildings and are never
criminally
charged what we see now with j6 is it's
plainly obvious to anybody it's it's
it's a farce it's a lie to the guys who
are fighting cops lock them up 20 years
seems a little excessive if you ask me
few months but you look at antifa during
Trump's inauguration when they marched
around the city smashing windows and
setting fires not only were these people
never they were arrested they were
released their charges were dropped and
then the city paid them millions and and
more importantly by by comparison to
that particular situation after uh
Trump's inauguration was that the
Department of Justice tried to prosecute
these cases they were getting hung
juries and acquittal in court and so
they went screw it and they just
dismissed the rest of them and of course
that is because of the DC makeup of a
jury I mean when you're talking about 92
and a half% of the jurors or the jury
pool they're voted for Biden
anyway it's it's a fate a complete
before your jury selection ever even
happens it's it's not going to go your
way and of course what the Department of
Justice has done and what every judge
that is in inside on this uh colluding
in this cartel that they have developed
or what I call a Star Chamber is they
have decided that there's not going to
be a change of venue motion granted to
anyone regardless of those circumstance
ances regardless of the polling
regardless of the the data the actual
evidence that you cannot get a fair
trial there it's
99.75% conviction rate right now on
January 6 Trials
95.75% of the cases they
win it's crazy it's because it's because
it's political if you take the a average
of just over 60% compared to 99.75 you
can't help if you're an honest broker
whatsoever except to conclude that this
is a political problem why hasn't Donald
Trump filed a lawsuit against egene
Carol and West
Virginia well obviously he should but my
question is we watch this stuff happen
over and over and over again in New York
to Donald
Trump why where are the Republicans to
literally file the same suits where the
where the prosecutors in uh these
Republican states to file charges
against these political organiz ations
they're just not doing anything all of
the attorneys that I work with right now
they all say the exact same thing if
every single one of these January 6
defendants had been tried in their home
District before a jury of their peers
that it would have been a 50/50
proposition in terms of conviction
versus acquittals and so you have to get
outside of of the Beltway in order to
get a fair trial there and that's and
and and honestly this is this is my
fight if I have to go there it's not
going to be um like JD Rivera's fight
it's not going to be like Steven Horn's
fight I have the advantage of having
watched from the bench in their trial I
have the advantage of watching how they
treated the oathkeepers I have a I have
are are you going to go for a bench uh
if if I had to choose for it it would be
a bench trial absolutely I wouldn't do a
jury trial the risk there is that the
judges are corrupt too well you have at
least you know the jurors are corrupt
maybe you'll get lucky and get that
fatten right right or or you you you get
them at a time like for instance we now
know that in Chambers that these judges
are talking about this 1512 obstruction
of official proceeding trial a charge
that scotus has agreed to take up we
know that in Chambers they're saying oh
yeah scotus is going to scrap this thing
yep which is going to send the entire j6
uh um routine into into complete chaos I
mean people are going to get their
charges what resend it or how's that
going to work that's what they've got to
figure it out I mean I
imag the obstructing official the
obstructing official proceeding the
challenge to it is it it was a literal
reference to destruction of documents
not marching through a building which
bothered someone correct that's exactly
it so scotus is going to rule and
probably say yeah the law was made for
this reason not for protesters M sh and
and it's already uh creating chaos
because individuals who have already had
that charge on them for maybe maybe
their maybe their charging documents
were executed a year or two years ago
and they're just now getting to trial
obviously their their motions are being
made by their defense attorney uh no we
we need to delay the trial until this is
decided by scotus and the judges are
granting that and then additionally some
they've actually some of the judges have
let people out of prison that because
the only reason they were in prison was
because of the 15 some people have
already been released yes they've
actually already released some of them
they've sent them home conditionally
until this thing is is settled wow U so
it's it's already it's it's already
creating problems the as I said the the
reaps uh
sentencing uh s shock waves through I
mean I don't know how going forward that
they can sentence a misdemeanor
defendant now to prison time after what
have you said what you think they'll
charge you with uh they they won't tell
me as I mentioned before um my in my
first interview with the FBI they said
look it's not our it's not our place to
decide we're just going to turn this
information over to the doj if they
decide to charge you it's probably going
to going to be just the four basic
misdemeanors but when they did notify me
that I was going to be charged in
November of
21 one of the charges that they were
going to hit me with was Interstate
racketeering what I'll just let that
marinate for mon well what is that what
is that because I had licensed and made
money off of the sale of my videos so
they're admitting you're a journalist
right right exactly this is we're going
to go to Super Chat so if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and head over
to
timcast.net so become a member support
our work directly and also don't forget
to buy facts by Tom McDonald featuring
Ben Shapiro at facts withth ben.com it
would be if if there was if if if there
was anything I could buy if someone
offered me like right now you can buy
something well to be honest I'd say like
justice for J Sixers I'd say you know uh
uh winning the culture War but right now
the one grain of sand we can throw in
that Heap is making Ben chapiro a
Billboard Hot 100 rapper and that would
that would please me ever so greatly
here we go
Christopher Lambert says and once more
that's right sir you are the first Super
Chat Jam says fourth unfortunately you
are second there you go big 7588 says
the problem with us Healthcare is the
patients it's the Americans who eat a
bunch of really really bad food you
know let's grab some uh what do we got
Jacob parody says hey Tim could you
please please my future could you please
my future niece's business a shout out
that's what he wrote It's called narb
Bar's candles she just joined Public
Square and I thought she could use a
boost here's to the parallel economy
here here sweet start those businesses
man challenge that machine shout out to
Public Square yeah it's cool that Public
Square can give people another way to
promote their their their new business I
mean the people who shop on Public
Square are pretty loyal to it they have
Public Square has centralized the
ability to help build the parallel
economy and challenge woke institutions
I love it so once once they become their
own store akin to Amazon but we know
that they're not selling garbage and
investing money in bad ideas you know
it's going to be convenient for
everybody and that's where we got to get
to we got that point of convenience the
drunk conserva conservative says Tim did
you see the daily wire story about the
Disney Dei wheel of power and privilege
that was hanging up in the theme parks I
think I did see that somewhere I'm not
sure though is that a scary ride it
sounds like a really scary
ride Corporate America shaking their
boots they're like we do this every
Thursday
all right let's go Port film Co-op says
find and watch Europa the last battle
what is that is that about migration in
Europe or something I'm not sure I
haven't heard of it or is it about the
moon around Saturn yeah I was thinking
like spaceships spaceships fighting
aliens in Saturn or is is no it's
Jupiter is iter Jupiter one of those
Europa IO ganam it's about ination to
one of the moons one of those fake
planets in fake
space the alleged planets in space I you
know for some reason I just know a bunch
of moon
names I think that's a good skill man
yeah it's good while Tim pulls up
another one I just want to say real
quick I checked Twitter and people are
sending me AI nudes of Nancy Pelosi I am
not happy okay but you brought up like
three times you're like oh my go he
really wants it Shane was like don't
send me these photos my wife is like oh
you're just adding more to the fold my
goodness can I'm single can I put in my
order right now you're interested in
Nancy
Pelos your handle out so people know
where to send it exactly all right
tricky re says the NFL is the same as
WWE it's Sports entertainment along with
NASCAR the NFL and ml MLB and so on if
it's broadcast sports it's rigged on
some level what there was like some big
NBA rigging Scandal wasn't there tons
wasn't it like they extended the the the
finals to get extra games to make more
money or something like that yeah just
if it was like if it was going like the
last game and then there was the chance
for an extra game they would yeah game
an extra game is BR is tons of money and
there have been like refs from
professional sports that have been fired
when it comes out that they are the ones
betting on the games right like or the
ones getting endorsements from like
particular groups to make the game last
long right there are corrupt people
everywhere Sports I saw a funny video
recently of of Michael Jordan who was
playing on the Wizards and and he the
ref didn't see the thing that happened
that was a foul and Jordan tells him
that was definitely like a foul and he's
like I didn't see it but I believe you
Michael
all right T-Rex Pet Shop says maybe gen
Z is voting for Trump because they don't
want to be drafted in World War III
Trump will be more likely to negotiate
peace that is
correct Eric CK says Tim I see your
videos with tens of thousands of views
on Tik Tok all the time so we made new
accounts because that's the way Tik Tok
works you get banned you make a new
account it's a better way to do it but
still their Bannings are BS but more
importantly other people are posting our
videos and clips on Tik Tok and it's
whatever you should everyone should post
clips from this show and whatever show
on those platforms and uh I will say the
same thing posting Clips very different
from posting the whole show the whole
show you know that's that's that's a
problem but uh post millennial post
Clips in the show all the time we love
it if you want to take clips that you
think are that are from the show that
you think are good and important please
clip that partion of the show and share
it and uh more importantly I hope on X
when you do so you make money by doing
it one of my favorite ones was was on in
I think it must have gone to Tik Tok
first but I saw it on Instagram getting
sent you and uh was it Destiny and it's
your like famous now hold on a minute
moment that wasn't destiny that was
Lance okay that was Lance sorry I get
everyone's name's mixed up but when he
said that abortions are okay at any
point it's the mother's choice but the
mother shouldn't be allowed to do drugs
cuz it would kill the baby wild I was
like hold on there hold on there a
minute had like my Instagram is like not
political at all I'm sure it knows on
some level but like to suddenly see TI
come up I was like wow this must be
going quite viral that clip went Mega
viral with like tens of millions of hits
because what they did was it's Lance
from the surf saying I was I was like
you think a woman could have abortion
you should have you know be able to have
abortion up to any point even at the
point of birth like her body it's her
choice and then I was like what about
meth and he was like well no because
that would kill the baby and then I said
hold on there a minute and then they
inserted Dave Chappelle going got you
and that was it good one that that
version of it got tens of millions of
hits or something of course it went
viral because you rarely get Galaxy
brain takes like that I had I had a
bunch of very high-profile people
hitting me up after that clip it was a
wild dude like like a week or two two
weeks later I have like very
high-profile person hilarious send me
this message and be like what the and
I'm like yeah yeah it's the show you
should watch it yeah like IRL I'm
sitting here like for real
like well it's funny because what they
do is there's like a clip where it's
like Lance schools like
like destroys Tim pool on the rise of
LGBT or trans kids I never disagree with
him on that issue he held up a piece of
paper saying the rise of left-handedness
and I was like oh okay interesting and
then they're like ah he got him and I'm
like but I didn't disagree with him I
was like I don't understand my favorite
right now is the vosch and anak
casparian made videos where it's like
Tim pool cheers for child labor you know
what I cheered for 16 and 17year olds
being able being able to work part-time
jobs you crazy person it's so it's like
Vos goes people like Tim pool and
conservatives are trying to exploit
children to make them work because the
children yearn for the mins which is a
meme that's fine but it's just like bro
my argument was that if you're 16 or 17
you're allowed to have a 30-hour a week
job and it's like yes I had a summer
like who who didn't have a summer job I
had had a paper route at 11 I was just
going to say I was working at that age
too I was mucking horse stall when I was
16 I worked fast food 32 hour 32 hours a
week I I don't but you know what it is
what was crazy to me is at first I was
like they're misrepresenting me i' I'm
saying like kids should work paper
routes and kids should mow Lawns when I
say children should work I'm talking
about shoveling snow for 10 bucks or
like working like helping your parents
the mom and pop shop and I thought they
were misrepresenting me that was
generating fake outrage a lot of it was
like Vos and Anna absolutely like they
took my tweet about 16 17y olds being
able to work 30 hours a week but I found
on Reddit they genuinely think
10-year-olds shouldn't mol shouldn't
take out garbage shouldn't shovel snow
and I that was like Wow and the comments
were things like to force a child to
understand the misery of working for
minimum wage and I was like like I'm I'm
mowing lawns they're like this is why we
need abortion it literally life is too
hard there's a yeah there's a clip of me
they say this though like I never agreed
to be born why do I have to work
psychotic so there was a clip of me from
this show where I'm literally like I'm
not saying work in factories I'm saying
kids should work at a mom and pop shop
and help take out the garbage and the
ments were literally like that is abuse
how dare you and I was like wow I am
soing myself right now for
you yeah children they yearn for the
minds though all right well where we at
let's grab some more Super chats James
Richard says as an Empire only wins a
war if the people fight for one for one
another this nation America will not the
ti is be fighting with each
other yes that's the uh that's the crazy
reality man all
right where we at jet storm says I'm
honestly terrified about any case of War
my mom uncles fought my mom's uncles
fought in World War II Vietnam and have
seen is my grandfather was in
Korea what what the hell was their
sacrifice for if I go I'm done and
Spanish double down now I got to be
honest when I when I think about like
the
koreas I understand if you came to me
and said we are going to troops into
Vietnam to stop the spread of Communism
I go oh there's questions about like the
us and whether or not we should have a
role in any of these any of this
expansion but we're not in an era of
global communist
expansion and I think for a lot of the
young Communists in the United States
they were upset about the draft and
going to war and all this stuff so I'm
not a big fan of foreign intervention in
any capacity especially if like some
other country I don't care about is
becoming communist but I can at least
understand the fear of Communism taking
over surrounding the United States
cutting it off and then strangling us
out now what do we have why were we in
Afghanistan or Iraq like I'm not even a
fan of going to Vietnam over communism
but I can at least understand understand
the threat of Communism you know
especially nowadays it's really funny
because it's like what was the
sacrifices for it's like well I guess to
stop communism didn't work the
Communists are taking everything over so
what's the global expansionist threat
now anti
communism the global uh uh the elite the
world economic Forum fears Donald
Trump no all right Scott colum said
colum says the military is currently not
requiring a high school diploma or a GED
to enlist suggesting that we're going to
war probably soon I believe that was uh
two years ago it was 2022 when they
removed those requirements so it's been
it's been a while
now Joe Robo this says Joe Rob okay
there just two zeros enlisting illegals
into the military would NE would negate
the check and balance that US soldiers
would never follow orders to attack US
citizens illegal enlists would
absolutely fulfill such attacks there
are already many people who are promised
citizenship in exchange for service that
that actually happens it's kind of funny
service guarantees citizenship they go
to these people and say if you serve
four years we'll give you your
citizenship yeah and this is already
this is already happening in the Civil
War correct with like the Irish
immigrants coming across uh at is island
or whatever they just hand a muskets and
then send them to the front of war w
that's true yeah you need baddies yeah
cam gasa says war with Iran government
enacts emergency powers and arms
illegals illegal Army used to oppress
citizens pretty high chances that's what
happens still think culture is the
answer Tim still think we got time for
breeding to fix this well War happens we
make it through War we have an election
coming up in November the foot
everything that's happening in this
country uh in this country and in the
world is not going to go away if Donald
Trump is elected or if you do literally
anything it is like it is no matter what
you do you are taking a ballpen hammer
to a
skyscraper the issue right now is can we
get Donald Trump at the top of that
skyscraper and start making sub
substantial internal changes for the
time being yeah we need to and we need
everyone to work together to start
building Alternatives so that we can
move past this but more importantly as I
watch Taylor Swift struggled to get
8,000 people to register to vote out of
her 272 million followers it makes me
think about just a total collapse of
everything when I was looking at the
when I I was I'm looking at the
numbers uh I'm looking at Ben Shapiro
and Tom McDonald they're number one on
iTunes and Spotify and um based on those
positions Plus on YouTube plus the
amount of views he has uh the amount of
views the song has and the plays on on
Spotify I'm like it looks like they're
going to actually chart and a lot of
leftists are saying iTunes doesn't even
matter anyway because nobody buys songs
anymore explain how does that make sense
nobody buys songs so who cares if Ben
Shapiro sells more songs than anyone
else that actually is kind of
contradictory the statement would be
holy crap Ben Shapiro convinced people
to buy music again Tom McDonald and Ben
Shapiro are actually able to command
more Sals more sales than
celebrities like when remember Napster
and Metallica but anyway yeah I'm
thinking about all this and I'm like the
only way they get these big artists on
the top of these charts is because
they're forced onto the streaming
playlists Spotify Apple whatever they
will be like this is a band we're going
to put them at the top and put them in
rotation because everyone knows who they
are that
manufactures radio plays and streams so
someone made a good point there are like
uh uh workout routine playlists people
go to the gym put on their headphones
and and press workout and it plays a
bunch of music they don't care about
don't care about the person don't care
about the song We'll never buy the song
but that that that hit put them on the
charts what is more important I think
sales is the only metric right now that
matters I don't care if Taylor Swift was
put on the new streaming playlist and
they gave her the number one spot that's
meaningless number one sales like I said
if Taylor Swift could convince 272
million people to buy one song for a
dollar she would do it she can't it's
all fake it's all it's all manufactured
started to realize that if Ben if if so
we we got uh I think the total sales we
got for together again was between 26
and
28,000 uh songs which is our biggest
release ever the last I think uh uh
genocide was like 18 or or 20 and only
uana was like 20 and so this one was was
a bit bigger with help from the daily
wire and we we hit number one in sales
on iTunes on all these platforms and I'm
like if we can command more influence
than even these big artists the the only
real issue is that they it used
billboard used to
be if if you sold the most you were the
top position then they changed it to
like radio play and stuff like that but
ultimately the point is you used to need
a million sales to be on the top of the
charts now nobody cares nobody's excited
for the new song by the band anymore
nobody is going out being like yeah now
it's like I'm sitting at the uh we're at
the casino in hard rock seminal and they
played a song by Paramore that has like
6.6 million streams on YouTube and I
look I'm not I'm I'm a big fan of
paramar one of my favorite bands but
this song is not culturally relevant and
it's playing on the lby Great for all
these people and I'm just thinking to
myself why did they choose to play a
song that nobody listens to it's all
manufactured but my my main point here
is if it's possible for someone like
bench up here on Tom McDonald to get at
the top of the charts it just shows that
American culture is completely shattered
there is
no there there's no unifying culture
anymore and I'm thinking to myself like
man if War happens it's just bedum in
this country no one's going to Rally
behind anybody it's just
it's just chaos factions will instantly
form various regions might break off and
form their own defensive packs and it's
not because any of them are mad at the
United States it's because if World War
III starts a small community in North
Dakota says we need to figure out how we
keep food and water flowing they form
pacts with other other groups they're
not listening anymore to DC because
they're so far away outside out of mind
and then you'll end up with the North
Dakota or the the the the the north
Midwest Regional Alliance it's not a
faction formed out of hatred for the
government it's a faction formed out of
necessity to secure resources at a time
of mass conflict and War around the
world that's what that's kind of how I
see things you know potentially going
but whatever we'll read some more Super
chats all right Joel xline says LOL Tim
even Alex Jones wouldn't go that far to
say Swift and Kelsey's relationship is
put together by a publicist that's silly
bud are you is that a joke you can look
up all the celebrities that are fake I
it is a common Trope where celebrities
will meet and the publicist will say so
here's the point of the meeting we want
your football player to date our singer
and here's the plan it's going to
generate x amount of views it's going to
increase your que rating blah blah blah
they do it all time it's G to promote
this movie they just both filmed like
it's I think it's super fun they do it
all the time and there's a breakup
here's a good example it's a conspiracy
theory I don't it's not factual as far
as I know but it's in a bunch of books
I've been looking into in terms of
Hollywood there's people that claim that
Robert Mitchum was they that the weed
story was manufactured to create a bad
boy image people always say Robert
Mitchum was the first celebrity arrested
with weed and there's claims that that
was all a manufactured story to present
a different type of character for him W
he would be cool here we go cool Jeff
Bader says obligatory payment for tul
praise my friends yes not only is tul a
great band but Maynard in A Perfect
Circle uh has one of the best songs ever
and it's Judith I I recommend you
actually listen to the lyrics read the
story of how he wrote Judith how it came
to a be and then uh the follow-up songs
he wrote about his mom long story short
I've talked about it it is
amazing his mom uh suffered a stroke he
then wrote a song criticizing her faith
in Christ and in God because he couldn't
understand how she would keep praising
God despite him having condemned her to
a life of
paralysis and it's actually interesting
because the song is both the son's pain
and anger and confusion but at the same
time a message about his mom's faith and
her unwillingness to waver despite the
hardships she faces and then later on he
wrote about how he finally you know
talked to her and understood how she
really felt just and it's a great song
The the guitar playing man but then of
course sober is just one of the best
songs ever written so I love them both
it depends on the day yeah you could
offer me up any Taylor Swift song and I
just be like I will put sober on Loop
forever Tool's one of the shows I've
ever seen she's not writing for you
she's writing for girls no I'm just
kidding and that's fine I got no beef I
like to Swift too okay so now some I
like Paramore Paramore is really good
although I think I I don't use AI I
don't like AI but someone out there
should probably make Taylor Swift
singing sober oh please that would be
awesome that's her next surprise song at
her concert dude could how do you do
that I don't know but I see people I saw
kany someone did Kanye doing somebody I
used to know and it sounded kind of good
like for in terms of like they knew
Kanye couldn't hit a certain note so
they they the AI manufactured a certain
way I think it's Taylor singing sober
and tulle playing Shake It Off shake it
off or trouble yeah yeah yeah yeah
Maynard singing Trouble would be great
no but sober is so good I just put it on
while I'm skating I just yeah great
album all right we'll grab some more
Super chats
here NY bsfp says Tim the sorest thing
is being pushed by people that actually
know better but have decided to fight
the war using the enemy's rules that's
it except the problem is
it's not the enemy's rules to sabotage
your opportunity I mean we we beaten it
to a dead we beaten a dead horse okay if
Taylor Swift says Soros bad you go
Taylor Swift wow she's so smart and
great I me I I explained this when I us
to do nonprofit fundraising Rapport is
the first thing you have to have in
order to make it to to to pitch someone
on on your cause to get them to sign up
you walk up to someone wearing a Taylor
Swift shirt on the street the first
thing you should say is I love Taylor
Swift swifties and high fivr and they're
be like you like tlor supped to be like
yeah name a couple songs you may have
heard on the radio like dude trouble was
so awesome and I really did think it was
funny how they did the goat memes on
that one but it's a good song did you
ever hear about how she was complaining
about how Sora stole all her music
that's how you do it don't give up the
opportunity man that's brutal at
conservative dads everywhere this is how
you connect with your teenage daughters
yeah wear it wear a Taylor Swift shirt
of her with a quote of her saying Soros
ster music the Highlander says twist
ending Taylor gets pregnant prompting a
mass baby boom just to Switch and Go Pro
abortion causing the world's biggest
child sacrifice no I think she if she
goes uh that's how I feel Pro kid it'll
stay I hope so look guys we just have to
embrace the fact that she's going to
turn our birth rate around and I think
that's good if you have not already my
friends please smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.net and actually call into the
show but you have to be a member for at
least 6 months or sign up at the $25 a
month level it's a screening process to
keep out the the weirdos and the
activists and the shills so uh but sign
up you'll support our work directly you
can follow the show at timcast IRL
follow us on Instagram you can follow me
personally at timcast Steve do you want
to shout anything out yeah probably the
main reason I'm not in jail yet is the
work that we've been doing at the Blaze
the revelations that we've made in terms
of the uh the corruption the capital
police uh the fact that we have shown
conclusively that some federal officers
have lied in court in these trials and
more to come right on right now yeah are
you on Twitter or any of those yeah
Twitter uh at TPC 4usa TPC the number4
USA nice well it's been awesome having
you here I was so grateful you could
come talk about your January 6 I think
it's really great than you yeah it's
really important to keep that alive
because I think people are apt to forget
at times uh I'm Hannah C remla I'm a
writer for scanner news that's cnr.com
you can follow our work if you follow
timcast newws on Twitter on Instagram if
you want to follow me personally I'm on
Instagram at han. and on Twitter at
hcpro so nice to see you Shane it was
great it was an infuriating conversation
hearing about the the judges and what's
going on with with the j6 stuff but uh
thank you for the work you're doing um
I'm Shane Cashman it's January 29th 2024
the neurolink just got put in the first
human skull and Elon I'm imploring you
to let me follow this person to write a
story for scanner as sc.com we have many
mutual friends on Twitter and i' hope
they reach out on my behalf and tell you
this story needs to be written I think
it's more interesting than space
exploration to be honest um and at Shen
Cashman everywhere thank
you and uh I am surge.com uh I am ready
for the after show whenever you are Tim
and uh I'm not cutting my hair all right
we will see you all over at Tim cast.com
in a minute or so thanks for hanging
out
that